i am so fired up for this very special
episode of the coffee with kennel show i
have some guests with me heather taurus
omar alta corey and tony ariola and we
are going to be reviewing your youtube
channels now listen if you
are watching on the replay there's going
to be a lot of strategy and nuances that
you can apply even if you don't get your
channel reviewed and if you check out
the live chat instructions for
getting your channel reviewed will be
posted there but grab some water grab
some tea or even better grab some coffee
because this is the coffee with kennel
show and we're getting into it right now
three two one
[Music]
welcome back to the coffee with kennel
show my name is sean cannell cheers
today's episode is brought to you by
thinkmediasale.com we'll talk about that
a little bit more in a bit but i want to
welcome to the stream with me omar
alticori heather taurus and tony areola
full stack this is like the first time
ever on the coffee with kennel show omar
what are you sipping on today
i already had my coffee you woke up
early but i got some sparkling honey
crisp apple juice kind of festive
[Music]
harvesty
how about you heather
i mean i already did two cups of coffee
in my amazing utah mug
and then i've got a whole thing of water
here for this stream so my goal is to
get through this today what about you
tony
this is actually pure vodka no i'm just
kidding it's uh it's coffee i'm here
with the coffee squad and uh stoked on
coffee with kennel you know i'm usually
on the back the back end here helping
with stuff and i'm excited to be here
with you guys on the stream today
yeah if you're just meeting of course
you might know omar from our think media
channel as our lead uh content creator
and camera expert miss heather taurus
the uh mrs heather taurus the clarity
coach and uh author of youtube made
simple a book coming out soon in 2022
and um a multi-million viewed youtube
creator and then tony ariola is our
youtube resident youtube strategist and
director of our video racket academy
program so we're pumped to dive into
your channels right here
i'm gonna have heather start off with
the first channel review um in just a
second but um smash like if you're fired
up to be here today it's good to see you
here live
architectural metal 101 melissa good to
see you randy if you're on facebook
throw a heart on the stream and hit the
share button because in fact if you
share this on facebook we're giving away
copies of youtube secrets this is
actually the korean translation we'll be
giving away um the us version either um
just by sharing on facebook
or leaving a comment on youtube so go
ahead and click that share button over
there we have a lot of fun today and
it's really good to see you mr fred fine
tip creative studio all right uh heather
uh what's the first channel
well i'm getting back in here uh for all
of these channel reviews we've actually
posted exactly how to enter so you can
uh see that inside of our uh inside of
our comment section but we're gonna
start out with our first one which is
the three
count the three count thank you so much
for the super chat and i mean come on
guys look at this channel already i mean
you can see branding happening you can
see exactly what this channel is about
with this wrestler right here and then
when you click in i mean i'm seeing this
is really cool just being able to see
the graphics that are happening now
here's a couple things the three count
uh i want to recommend a video to you
that nolan mult from the think media
team did where he actually uh reviewed
or gave insight into the best thumbnails
i think you definitely are on branding
with your thumbnails
but with that uh there's a lot of words
happening in your thumbnail so you want
to pair that down
in your thumbnails try and get at least
three words or less in there because
right now there's a lot of words
happening but your question that came in
was i generally post i generally post
wrestling interviews with lesser known
wrestlers which generally means lesser
views how should i work around this and
i want to show you over on our think
media podcast channel how we do this so
i have been doing different interviews
on our podcast channel uh where i am
sharing
let me go stop share and reshare where i
am sharing insights from our uh video
ranking academy students and when this
happens
um you will see that we're actually or
even katherine manning other other
actual creators we are titling the video
like a video so rather than it being
titled with the name of ben azadi here
which is uh another youtuber and fellow
uh content creator we actually titled
the video as the title so let me zoom in
here for you a little bit so you can see
this the title of this video is how to
turn your youtube channel into a six
figure business that is the topic
that i interviewed him around so i went
into the interview understanding what i
wanted the topic to be about and i
already chose the title before going
into it you notice you actually don't
even see ben azadi's name until it's
down here because while he's known in
his niche he's not necessarily well
known to the world if i were to be
interviewing um
like candace owens that's a little more
known than ben azadi so
i could put the name there if it is a
well-known person but i would recommend
that when you are titling your videos
that you title them with the search
based keywords in mind over
the actual name of the person i hope
that helps and gives a little insight
into that anyone else want to offer
anything up on that one yeah i would say
that if for anybody's doing an interview
type show um one of the strategies i
would encourage you with is kind of like
heather said you're if the person you're
interviewing doesn't bring influence
that much and maybe won't bring the
views the topics and the trending topics
will and so when you're planning an
interview with anybody in your niche
what i would encourage you is maybe try
to go over five topics with them in the
entire long interview maybe it's five
trending topics maybe it's five tips for
things is it that five those five tips
now are not only a full-length interview
but then you could chop those five tips
into separate videos to help leverage
those interviews at a higher level and
we do this all the time on our channel
so you can watch what we're doing on the
podcast versus our think media channel
but that's just a little extra strategy
to throw in there for getting more views
on those interviews
yeah and i think the final thing as uh
we queue up the next channel review is
um
i think content formats are a big deal
for everybody watching meaning
interviews i think in general are going
to have a lid on them they're kind of
educational they're informational i hope
you're also maybe doing a podcast
because i think you could have a lot of
opportunity on spotify and apple that
people are commuting they want to listen
to these conversations or
you know why they're doing errands but
maybe harder to get or you run into fair
use or you got to go to matches
but imagine
crazy clips or compilation clips of
you know at wrestling itself i think the
amount of views and interest from a
wider audience even if it's lesser known
people if it's crazy highlights of
certain types of moves
that means pivoting content formats a
little bit if that breaks your vision
outside of the interview style that
you're wanting to do well then maybe you
don't want to go outside of your vision
but all of us maybe have to be willing
to step outside of the content formats
we're doing um if we really want to see
maybe
explosive growth all right who's next
all right uh tony the super chat came in
from the movie pie and i've got that in
there for you let's go ahead and uh
review the movie pie
yep give me one second to just
find that in the private chat here got
it all right so this question came in
from the channel the movie pie and thank
you again for all you guys super chats
we're going to get to all when we can
we're gonna put you at the front of the
line if it's a five dollar or more super
chat says yesterday i changed my channel
name from trey mccable
my future author name to the current
name i did it to be clear to potential
viewers was this a good decision
now i would say this it really depends
on your end goal now maybe you have the
same question you're like hey i don't
know what's in my channel should you be
my name should it be like a like brand
name it really depends on your end goal
if you're trying to build a channel that
is all about your personal branding it's
all about you and you're trying to grow
your name as a personal brand
problem maybe having your channel as a
name would be a good idea now i will say
the thing that's nice about having
something called the movie pie
is instantly you kind of get what your
channel's about it's easier to
communicate that to people it's easier
for people to know what your channel is
about by just saying your name so it's
easier to get traction in that way if
you're trying to dominate a niche and if
you're trying to dominate this niche of
movies and movie facts reviewing the
movies i feel like the movie pie is
probably a good choice um to move to but
again
this is really comes down to a personal
choice i can't go you 100 should do this
but movie pie sounds like a good plan to
me heather and that's what i would say
amazing thank you so much movie pie all
right the next one is going to be fit
over 50. omar can take that one and then
sean the bearded id dad i.t dad is up on
deck
you're muted omar
all right fit over 50. um
i'm browsing too as we push through uh
some of your stuff i would say
like i always like would like to start
with good things uh dude your thumbnails
are legible
um they're they're really they stand out
you know like i definitely think if
you're you always gotta look think about
when you pull up youtube
and that's the that's how people are
going to find your videos is going to
pull up youtube and then you're
competing with everybody else but
because you can see
exactly um what your video is going to
be about in just three words or three
lines i want to say continue to do that
it looks like you made a small pivot uh
with your thumbnails to make them even
more um cleaner i would say maybe maybe
uh this might be a challenge but being a
fitness channel channel like
maybe it's helpful to have like your
full body in there you know because you
want to communicate that but it also
makes you very tiny so there is some
ways to work around how can you get more
of yourself in a shot um it looks like
your first video like fine wine is
highest viewed
uh video in the last
six videos which i would argue might be
just because that's the only one that
you could really see a face potentially
you know
and so i would just keep keep in mind
that stuff uh back to what tony said
about the last channel it's great that
your channel's a value proposition is in
the title of your channel and so um i
definitely think your the name of it is
strong
um
and uh that i mean those are the things
at a glance when i first see it um
i'll be clicking around too if anybody
else has something else to say it looks
like when you click on your uh your
website at the top right because i just
like seeing like what what does this all
point to that's so cool that you already
have your things set up uh based off of
uh the stuff you recommend and i would
assume that you know stretching videos
you probably got like the roller in that
or super smart so great to have that
like the last two people i think we just
reviewed didn't have that that like flow
lined up i saw the other one went to a
twitter account and then the last one
just redirects back to the youtube
channel so you're thinking you know that
this could be you know you're you could
start already making money with your
youtube channel so
yeah i would say yeah great job i mean i
mean i would it looks like you just need
to keep at it think about i think
doing the time stuff i think is really
strong like people when it comes to
fitness especially like me uh having the
time expectation in in your title and or
thumbnail is super helpful because i
know the expectation of what i'm getting
myself into you know and i think sean
could speak to this because he'll
occasionally do some stretching stuff as
well
yeah i think content formats is your
opportunity for growth strategically
meaning
you kind of allude to this as a 10
minute workout but that also was missed
in the title so understand viewers are
actually looking for
maybe a body weight workout for men over
50.
and this uh
this right here 10 to 15 minute workout
at home
is
it says it in the title with no
equipment the power of videos like this
is like i do um like yoga for wrists
and um
i have watched this risk care almost a
million viewed yoga for risk video with
yoga with adrian it's two years old i've
watched this video 28 times
all the way from start to finish
complete watch time
so
this video has probably generated even
with this niche it's probably generated
a couple thousand dollars already um in
terms of ad revenue and obviously
massive growth for her channel so as an
additional
content format um
not just listicle tips or how to do a
specific kit
kick or something but actual routines
that are very easy for people to do
at home i think are a major opportunity
um to um
get not just viewers but repeat viewers
and really hack the youtube algorithm
because of extreme levels of watch time
all right we're to be doing our next
channel check out the comments for how
to get in the queue of channel reviews
super chats are jumping to the front of
the line at a 5 or above level but today
is brought to you by thinkmediasale.com
if you haven't heard we are doing a
cyber week sale
on our youtube made simple course which
if you are on your journey to your first
1 000 subscribers and earning your first
1 000 online you're gonna love this
program at a major discount and so check
this out and then we're going to jump
into the next channel review did you see
thinkmediasale.com
for the holidays we're giving you 80
off our brand new youtube made simple
course bundle
get over
nine hundred dollars worth of our best
courses tools templates and more just go
to thinkmediasale.com
yeah so check out
thinkmediasale.com to see not just the
youtube made simple discount but there's
two extra bonuses our youtube starter
kit which will give you our thumbnail uh
custom thumbnail training video title
ideas um and uh our list of video ideas
a title swipe file and our four hour
youtube strategy training uh strategy
workshop with tony and omar myself and
heather and so again you can check all
of that out at think media sale
dot com but coming up next we have the
bearded it
dad and um
this is a super cool channel immediately
i t makes sense and of course networking
cyber security it looks like
uh you definitely have found a strong
niche here 13 uploads oh by the way i
noticed on the fit over 50 you haven't
uploaded in two months
one of the secrets you know not to be
condescending at all but one of the
secrets to getting views on youtube is
posting videos on youtube so um
sometimes you see a correlation between
the amount of hustle of course the
amount of uploads uh this is i'm
inspired by your hustle here because
your upload percentage is up 225 percent
so you're definitely hustling hustling
year-end and we're seeing growth across
the board with the increase
at bats if you will of posting content
but no i love the niche and there's so
many niche it questions
maybe people this looks like other
people want to follow in your footsteps
how to maybe do an i.t job how to get it
certifications
i think that's interesting
it looks like a lot of things on on your
journey there
tony any thoughts on this channel
yes i do have thoughts on this channel
actually i actually have a really good
friend of mine who just got into the it
field and he was talking about um
some of the things he had bought in like
even on black friday i mean obviously
that's just passed but he bought them
black friday like tests that were on
sale and different topics that were
trending because oh i need to get this
sale it's amazing it's just a great way
to take advantage of the holiday season
some of these like tests that cost a lot
of money are actually on sale they
probably have an affiliate program
potentially um but also just think about
coming up with study guides you're
probably already doing that but think
about like people who are just getting
into the field and need those study
guides or the help to get through these
excruciating tests because he's just
telling me it's like these tests are
crazy and really hard to do so um that's
what i would look at probably doing some
videos like that your niche is
primo because it's such a niche that
people are trying to learn online from
already they're like going to online
resources to learn these things they're
already techies and so i think you're
positioned really well your branding's
on point and love it
i think the titles could use some work i
mean you're just repeat i.t career field
live q a you know notice today that even
here while we're in somewhat of
you know lots of different topics lots
of different tips lots of different
channels we led with how to get views on
youtube which was you know hopefully the
promise of also why you're here applying
these tips and even this advice that
we're giving to other channels will help
you get more views on youtube so you're
saying it career field live q a
that just doesn't have uh any
um juiciness to it like what what am i
gonna learn or what is a theme or a
topic
of what you may be covered that day and
if it's just open q a is it under
a certain theme you could cover and
something that's potentially
searchable so maybe you you talk all
about cyber security one day or whatever
and and i guess i'm a little bit because
i understand it would seem that you
really
want to help others get into a career it
i mean that seems what it is because
it's all about the career it's maybe not
even about the specific tech how do i
enter the i.t field
how to make a career out of it so to sum
up tony's advice i think um if you want
channel growth you've got to ask
yourself the question
do i need to broaden my scope you you
don't seem to be doing product reviews
which is fine but if you cover certain
routers or hubs or you know switches or
or comparing like you'd probably be
surprised if you compared cat5e even i'm
sure people have done this
like versus videos and we'll get ready
for this next channel here but
um
one of our favorite uh things right now
because this is actually a question i'm
thinking about questions i have cat 5e
versus
cat6 now of course you're going to reach
consumers so you got to ask yourself
i mean 2.2 million views answering
specific questions
644 000 views talking about what's the
difference on cat5 cable
so you're educating consumers but some
of these videos might draw in new
audience
and by drawing a new audience you also
might say and hey by the way if you want
to subscribe i help people get started
in a career in i.t
and uh if you kind of geek out on this
kind of stuff hit the subscribe button
and and you might reach a lot of people
who just are on that consumer side
trying to make a purchase on amazon but
it also could lead you to a lot of top
line
growth all right heather uh who's next
um i was actually putting him in the
chat over there so why don't we go ahead
and do um architectural sheet i'm not
sure which one you have pulled up next
sean i just can't see on your screen
all right we got architectural perfect
sheet metal 101 love the niche tools
tips and techniques
love the creativity of the avatar up
here i almost wonder if i would rather
see your face asm 101 kind of makes
sense but
this is a good tip that generally you're
either going to do a logo right
on our channels or you're going to do
kind of a personal brand i just love
that you cut your head out put a white
border on there kind of gives a fun uh
it's clear but it also gives kind of a
fun vibe to it that might be interesting
here as well but that's not going to be
a major
needle mover
i do think that that's just a good
teaching point though i
uh anyone you know when you think about
your profile image
keeping 80 of your profile image your
face you know uh so that's why
it stood out so much to sean because
even in that circle you're taking up
about eighty percent of um that that
circle so that's why he would recommend
you know do that with um your uh profile
pic but that's just really great rule of
thumb
yep five uploads uh it looks like in the
last month go for green you know i want
to encourage you and anybody watching
you know
like
we compare ourselves don't compare
yourself to other channels just compare
yourself with yesterday and these stats
here using vid iq
just
says your subs are up 50 your views are
up 10 percent so that's great and uh
like going to most popular to kind of
see success leaves clues so make part
twos
um look at some of your top videos and
think about how you could double down on
them and make them again how to install
a chimney flashing how to answer
specific questions that's really good
how to walk on a metal roof safely
interesting um any thoughts on this
channel team yeah can you go to the
homepage real quick a lot of his
question was can you look at the
homepage to get a general feel of the
home page
i think one of the things i think when i
look at home pages is i want it to be
thought through as
a person coming to your channel that's
kind of interested might subscribe what
would you do to appetize them right so
thinking about how you build out those
playlists and if sean you want to show
like think medias for example our
homepage i've curated this home page to
almost have like mini playlists of
courses really like they're almost like
mini courses or mini like yeah just
playlists or video series you start with
the uploads remember think media podcast
is where you want to go people to go
next but then right here how to create a
youtube channel and make your first
video if people are just coming into
contact with us then maybe you're
checking us out maybe you want to start
on youtube this is a perfect playlist
for them to start at right you keep
going down cameras for dummies it's like
everything you need to know about
understanding how to work a camera is
all on a playlist there for you go to
lighting audio tips it's just curated in
a way where
people can kind of navigate and find the
things that they want to learn and so i
would think about how do you design your
homepage in a similar way
you know maybe there's certain playlists
that you're like this would be a great
way for people to go through my content
and then you can point people back to
that continuously and so i'd say your
homepage isn't bad popular uploads isn't
necessarily bad but shorts i think is
probably a really bad way to have on
your homepage because it just visually
doesn't look great
but i would think about building out
your playlists and trying to think
through
your you know viewers quote-unquote
journey to get to where you're at right
how did you start what would be most
helpful for them put that on your home
page and order it in that way that would
be my tips for you for the home page and
one tweet you could do here is always
title your playlists so that they can be
discovered in search how-to's
it could be how-to's for anything so it
could be
how-to's related to how to like sheet
metal how to's or or something that is a
little bit deeper on that same thing
with like live streams live streams
about what um you know
these could be richly written out to
tony's point
um the playlist titles are what
makes your home page
it are the categories and so if you're
watching this think about sometimes we
think about them like buckets what are
the
three to five to six buckets
of types of content so we think about
camera basics explained so this is the
playlist title to be clear cameras for
dummies youtube camera basics for video
explained very rich
youtube video lighting for beginners
everything you need to know so i think
your playlist titles could be more
search based and more almost uh like
it's like a headline it's a it's a it's
kind of a billboard and that then will
become the descriptors because right now
uploads popular uploads uploads shorts
chimney flashing video series like maybe
get a little sauce on that that makes me
want to watch
that series thanks so much for
omar go for it watching the last thing
is just to to not just go to his videos
just click on videos right there uh and
scroll down a tad it looks like you're
getting a little lazy with your titling
so just scroll up a little bit
to the top like
um
like on the on the
they're like lower case although you
know the one on zinc how to how is zinc
standing steam right there kind of like
the format of your title and then um
how to use a sheet metal like
your best performing videos are when
your titles are written out thoughtfully
you know capitalization
inten intentional
placement of all caps
you know parentheses separation
but some of your more recent how-to
videos they look like they were just you
know you quickly wrote it out copy paste
or something so just like go back and
just make your titles uh more legible
and enticing in regards to
your you know your uh more popular ones
next up we have the journey d-w-m-y-h
i think we see a lot of opportunities
right off the front here we don't have a
cover image
the avatar
is not legible the text is too small i
can kind of now see that it's it's a
it's the logo is inside of a
grayish logo which just bleeds into the
background so think about the power of
contrast you know people are either
watching youtube on a whitish gray
background or they have night mode on
it's dark
but your avatar just kind of disappears
there's a sub line on the avatar that's
not legible and it's in a font that's
not legible and so and then the journey
dw myh i don't i don't know what that is
so i would boldly say
i think even the channel name this is
just the first impression and you in a
way in 2022 you actually only kind of
get one chance to make a first
impression i mean any video that breaks
out
people then are going to be asking like
what's this channel about what what can
i expect here and so if you confuse you
lose and i'm
confused um and so those are the first
couple of things and so then i suppose
we could go to our about page
it's not written so there's nothing i
could really learn there and uh you do
have quite a few videos out and so
uh my next question is you're what you
you don't want to make the viewer work
and now i'm working very hard i'm
literally racking my brain to try to
figure out what this is about you want
to make it easy
you want to remove friction in the
viewer journey so that they can uh make
sense so now i'm so that they can make
sense of what it is
it definitely it seems like it has to do
with cars i mean the journey with
russell and chase
don't don't leave video titles
with
uh
i know this coaching is coming firm but
it's all said in love because i want you
to win and if you're watching this and
you can apply this to your channel we
want you to win
but i don't know what the journey is
like it actually is meaningless like
journey of life self-help channel
you know spiritual channel
is it a road trip channel is it i mean i
saw a wheel so i think this maybe has to
do with cars and i don't know who
russell and chase are and i know
obviously we need to eventually meet you
but what you're leading with back to
like heather talking about if you or the
wrestling channel if you're working with
somebody who's unknown
like we don't know russell we don't know
chase and then do what makes you happy
so i don't know like so and i think it's
about cars
you know what is this and generally
you're probably sending traffic from
somewhere because you do have 580 views
on this which is pretty cool
um but
think about
you know shop tour okay
but it should probably be like auto shop
tour there could be wood shops there
could be all kinds of different shots
our big plans
this could just it could be so
positioned differently in terms of a you
know auto shop tour
seven new upgrades to or something that
is a little bit more searchable
but also the final thing is that
um
you know some of these
they feel like they're just stating a
fact
like we're
installing a real link 4k security
camera
so
take a step back and think about
the viewer first and what value is the
viewer going to get i it does feel and
i'm kind of getting a vibe here a little
bit of a vlog channel a little bit of
people want to follow your journey
if they subscribe they want to click on
any video you upload no matter what the
title is
that
will probably just keep growth slow but
if you take it all the way back why
should someone watch this video
is it how to install the real link
um this one still has some clarity to it
because maybe somebody else that's
wanting to discover how to install this
wants to watch your video and your
documentation of it but then that's also
going to go into like the structure of
the content itself because if it's if
it's too
if it's a kind of vloggy first or you
know it does look
you know yeah this this makes a little
more sense you're teaching on it a
little bit so i think um i i know i've
given you some hard things to work on
but i think there's a lot of points of
improvement and and those types of
improvements and pivoting of getting
your tiles right your thumbnail right
getting clarity
on
who it is this channel is for
and then what exactly they should watch
the videos for if it's vlog and
entertainment being clear about that and
um if it's
how to pick engine parts uh any other
thoughts team before we hit the next one
no i'd agree with you um i think that
there's just so much potential but it's
just getting clear on
there's sometimes like there's a mindset
shift of going how can i think of the
viewer first
you know not that you aren't but just
how can you even more put yourself in
the shoes of your viewer and how they
are going to understand your content and
how they're going to understand what
they're going to get from you i think
that's one of the hardest things to get
into but at that mindset if you can get
into that mindset you can really unlock
a lot of these problems of titling how
you make the videos it really unlocks a
lot of domino effects so do whatever you
can to get into the into like their
shoes how they're seeing your content
and it's going to help you produce
better better stuff so
yeah appreciate you and and hope that
that gives you some strong things to
think about to really level up because
again um and from watching a little bit
too um your energy on camera the vibe
you guys have the ability to create
content the look of things i mean the
editing you got all the pieces uh
clearly you're producing content in a
great way so i think dialing in some of
these nuances will really um just help
you grow further
faster next up we have credit unions
training
um let's start breaking it down team
what are you seeing
i was clicking through and seeing some
stuff i think the
some things i initially noticed right up
from front was um
was that you uh
it looks like it's more than just a
personal brand thing um
because it you know you have a company
website thing on the top but i
definitely think it's one guy creating
content right and so i think there maybe
is a decision to make in regards to like
do you want the face to be the face of
the videos because it looks like it
probably is but all i see is like
corporateness in in your youtube channel
also look at your descriptions are kind
of uh they're empty so think through
like where do you want to send people
credit union dot training and your
hands-on training delivering so you're
you're helping with consulting synergy
credit union consulting so like it's so
important that you help people get to
where they need to go in regards to get
help and um you know the coaching
consulting space is such a cool thing on
youtube because you necessarily don't
need
a um you know a big you know
following because if you get the right
following it'll be awesome so sean just
clicked through and found the form and
it was had a great headline it said um
request proposal
like that might be where you want to
send people to you know on your banner
like and and in your videos hey why
don't you like fill out a free request
to to get you know whatever i'm just
saying like learning about sending
people to a place
uh when it comes to
making this work for your business um as
far as thumbnails go you can go you can
go a little bit more simple you know we
want we like to see faces and majority
of face like uh not chest up face but
like legit like
you know sternum and up um face and then
and then what are what's like three
three words or so that'll really
uh capture the person who who wants to
click on this video um just some things
to think about like i think i think the
branding can get cleaned up in regards
to thumbnails so just finding a clean
look if there's somebody you like
try to replicate it and canva is a great
resource to create really simple um
thumbnails and just to point at your
attention like on think media if you
need help with anything that we are even
talking about oh so sean just wanted me
to you know fill out my description go
to youtube go to think media's youtube
channel and just search whatever it is
you need help to do so in this case if
you want some thumbnail training go to
think media and just search the word
thumbnail and we'll have training on
different softwares that you can use if
you want to uh you know heather did a
cool training on how to like cut
yourself out of a photo so that you
could put whatever background
but we definitely
try to create an archive of videos that
can help you in your youtube journey so
just always know that that's available
so like all right any level of my
thumbnails just go to think media and
search thumbnails and
i i think i think your thumbnails will
definitely
clean it up for sure
and one of the most powerful things we
can all do is we really need to learn
the power of words in general to power
up our youtube channel i know that we
mainly think about cameras right we
think about the video side um but
when i say words the art form would be
called copywriting it's the art of
writing persuasive marketing copy this
is going to influence your titles but
specifically on this page um there's an
opportunity it's great you're linking to
your website and eventually
you link to the request you know reposal
but this could say something like click
here to get a free proposal
free could be all caps
when you're writing stronger words
you're wanting to drive an action and so
sometimes you might say you know
installing such a such security camera
click here to learn
you're actually giving a call to action
to the individual you know that is on
the site and as omar mentioned
what is the business result you want to
drive is it how many the more proposals
you get of qualified prospects that
could lead to business and again um
we'll we'll keep going if there's
anything else on this one but i want to
mention a resource on uh today's episode
of coffee with cannell was brought to
you by the fake mediasale.com
and
one of the things we've included in here
is our youtube
starter kit
and our youtube starter kit has our 15
best title formulas for getting views
this is just this is the kind of family
we've put together a great uh you know
sale here and you can check it out at uh
it's 80 off to get all of this at think
mediasale.com but just this these are
templates that we've made we haven't
really released this anywhere else to
just help you quickly craft
powerful words that get people to take
action
i'm sure all of us watching could learn
from
could benefit or will benefit from
writing better titles so dei keynote
part one you
like
i mean you just get it
whether you join the sale or not like
that could be a lot better like if we're
coaching you that's like a two out of
ten or like you know little maybe people
know what dei is so it's somewhat
searchable now three reasons loan review
is your financial institution's
competitive advantage is a little bit
better um but even still there's some
ways you could power up beyond that so
um any other thoughts team on this in
regards to this channel before we hit
the next one yeah i think the big
mindset shift too is this when you title
videos like kind of the way you're
titling them you're kind of
appealing to everyone in your in your
world really
but we're trying to encourage people and
whatever channel you have really to how
could you entitle it to like include the
world not just your world like the world
how could you reach a bigger audience
well a bigger audience is people coming
to youtube
searching for a problem and how are they
typing that in the search bar like where
are they at like how to get a loan
for no low income people or how to get a
loan for that's some of the stuff
they're gonna be typing in and when you
are there to answer their problem and
then you do what omar said you go hey
i'm here to answer your problem here's
here's what you got to do and if you
want like to like have a consult with me
you can actually check the link in the
description and i'll jump on the phone
with you and help you out
i mean that thing is going to get leads
for you it's going to convert and people
are going to go to your website and fill
out the form because you're there to
help them you've already helped them
once so the likelihood of them trusting
you to help them a second time is very
high so
that's all the reason why we're trying
to change your guys titles is because
you're only titling them for your maybe
your current subscribers and if you
don't have a lot that's not really a lot
a lot of traction and we want you to
reach the world not just your current
world
really good tony all right coming up
next we have ivan's channel and um we
are going to bring that one up right
here all about 100 fantasy football
right off the top um love the idea that
um
it's clear fantasy football that the
stated niche is the stated niche it's
very strong to do that um if you confuse
you lose clarity is power i think
to omar's eighty percent if you're going
to use your face in your avatar
uh if you're gonna use a logo i think we
could zoom in more fantasy football
could be stacked and the font could be
larger and the 100 could be larger cool
creative logo to utilize that emoji so
that's strong
um
i like these thumbnails like using the
the players there is something
interesting and we'll recommend you know
if you look up think media netflix
uh
nolan reviewed a study that studied
netflix thumbnails he's actually
modeling it in this thumbnail as well he
learned a couple things he learned kind
of the rule of three
the role of simplicity that that most
strong thumbnails on netflix which they
have all the science behind it have
three things in them there's nolan
there's the word netflix there's the
word youtube and youtube has the logo
but you see it's very simple
there's very simple plain background
blue background the camera the number
500
you know omar's video things are blurred
out you've got just the lens and the
phone and the background's kind of an
aesthetic
youtube logo text sean three things
phone sean
zero views so
there's something i think
by i
some of these thumbnails are busy and
you don't necessarily need
all of these different players and what
i've noticed on netflix that's
fascinating is you know they've they've
toyed around if anybody watched the
office uh back when it was on there now
it's on peacock or whatever they've
towed around with like that shot of
michael scott and everyone in the
thumbnail but you'll watch them test
thumbnails and sometimes they'll do just
michael scott or they'll do michael and
dwight or they'll do you know just pam
and and so
for you ivan but everybody man think
about how you can simplify your
thumbnails to make them what is like the
one thing that could be in the thumbnail
the one
uh character and you know when you are
the hero i think another good guy to
study
or rather if you're
you're the personal brand in the middle
put around you potentially just two
uh characters uh so when phil defranco
is leveraging influencers like dave
chappelle mr beast here it's him and
it's dave chappelle mr beast it's always
three it's like he i don't think he ever
really gets more the rock
you know ben
noi or barcelo portnoyed whatever that
guy's name is uh and then phil in the
middle so a couple things that i think
i like the the design that you're doing
and then you may not need
you definitely don't need to echo
fantasy football week 11 preview and
then in the thumbnail it says fantasy
football week 11 preview the text is
unnecessary
um
you're
echoing the text text almost exactly
and so
these these titles could also really be
leveled up do you want to speak to that
team
tony
yeah um i would agree with sean i think
that there's too many subjects in your
thumbnails i would also say that um
when you're talking about fantasy
football i would go i would go more
niche so like when you're looking at
your videos you're going fantasy
football you know uh players to cut i
mean that's that's okay but i would look
at fantasy players best wide receivers
to start this week or like best running
backs in fantasy football
week eight like i would that's the way i
would think about titling these things
and like breaking out and that's how you
could turn like you can make six seven
videos a week of you just sitting down
and going these are the best wide
receivers you're going to want to start
um and also if you want to pick up these
off your waiver in your league these
might be available for free agents and
talk about like each position
specifically
and then talk also about maybe what are
the best defenses what like that's the
level i would go if i wanted to put out
a lot of content and then come up with a
simple thumbnail template so you don't
get hung up like making thumbnails like
for a long time try to be really speed
rated meaning how do i do this fast so i
can do six thumbnails for all six of
those videos every week they're just
templated they're not me creating
something from scratch so that's the
strategy i would go with because
you never know which of those videos is
going to pop off plus
the data is very um
it expires right it's like the next week
it might not be the same answers and so
that's what i would think about with
fantasy football especially during your
season it's like go time right during
football season your channel that's like
the time
the the time to head down to be like
going after it because your channel is
only really active during the football
season you might have some stuff during
off season maybe you branch into other
sports on another channel you have a
fantasy baseball those kind of things
but yeah i would head down you can even
do live streams talking about these
things and then like i said earlier if
you do live streams you could cut those
live stream segments to be the wide
receivers the running backs the defenses
the you know tight ends and so that's
that's the strategy i would use and um i
think it's a great niche to be in though
really profitable and a lot of people
are doing it
all right uh pumped for this next one
this is make my
fun
uh making fun happen
uh i would number one good job of having
this
i would say one thing to improve on
though is like
based off of your title i like they're
they're it's too up in the air um i'm i
don't know like what this is even about
with the snapshot so always thinking
about
you know like what sean said a moment
ago about not making your uh person work
on like figuring out what this is
um i it's a little busy i would i would
less is more when it comes to graphic
design and honestly i can't stress
canva.com enough to help you with your
thumbnails your channel art your logo or
your uh your profile image um so what is
it like what and and when when are you
doing anything a good rule of thumb is
actually you can put an expectation on
your channel banner so if it was like
make my fun
and then like this kind of video every
monday at seven or whatever because i
cause as i scroll through
your videos it looks like you do like a
live stream kind of like kind of like
this you know um with with a few guys or
different people um in regards to
you know different things
however
just starting with like the cleanliness
i think would help and then that even i
think bleeds into again thumbnails and
so when i when i see your thumbnails
looks like you're putting in work
because although you see this you know
what i see i see the same i see a bunch
of the same thumbnail which isn't a bad
thing
because as i zoomed in i was like oh
they're not the same you're actually
putting the question
in the thumbnail based off of what
you're talking about and so this is this
is all just design real quick you don't
have to put the date um you know about
when this is because the point of
youtube is that it can precede the time
in which you create this uh video
uh so don't don't worry about the date
and then the the question if there's a
good rule of thumb just just title your
stream the question that you have on
these thumbnails it's like that's kind
of where you're bent anyway right so
like what do you do for rc parts uh rc
burnout what's your hobby giveaway like
frame around whatever this is based off
of what people potentially are asking
when it comes to rc's
and it looks like a lot of the things
have to do with rc so like make rc fun
or something like that in regards to
your channel name so i think it starts
with like just making it simple and then
and then
content strategy is does it need a
conversation that is two and a half
hours long
or
could you answer this question in eight
to ten minutes with just a simple
talking head video and like what tony
mentioned to reach more people
uh because you you need those
opportunities uh of videos that you
intentionally make to be like this this
is my opportunity we call it hero videos
like what are your hero videos on your
channel and if have you made them you
know
i would say hero videos typically for
the most part are answering specific
questions but you're going for it you're
going for like the wide reach of
answering those questions like seems
like for you to have a long form content
show on this type of stuff you have so
much value to offer when it comes to rc
stuff so like
what are those things what should people
be buying how you know speed versus test
when it because this is a product based
channel there are so many things that
you can go deeper with when it comes to
like products um and off-road versus
street racing you know
um so those are something i know that
when we do these channel reviews there's
a lot and it i think it's really just
picking one thing and if i were you i
would really clarify your your value
proposition with your name um and then
and then go from there cleaning up the
look
and then that's that's the one tip clean
it up and so clean up your content clean
up your logo clean up your thumbnails
and um and then you know stay consistent
i think it's good that you get in the
muscle of creating content
um nonetheless
like you you know what it feels like to
be on for an hour and 30 minutes that's
a good skill to have but now i think you
can you know
what is it when you make something
refine that skill and uh and get better
at making a powerful videos that are
shorter
yeah
i want to pass it off next to heather
unless somebody else has something else
to say
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna uh reset us
real quick and i wanna say thank you to
everyone that is on right now wow super
chats are coming in but the super chat
for reviews is closed uh so i wanna
thank everyone for being a part of this
do you like this kind of content let us
know by smashing the like button right
now let's get it to
150 likes for this stream we're going to
go strong here but i want to let you
know that if you're watching live or on
the replay that we have a special offer
for you right now right now we're doing
free channel reviews but if you want to
figure out the step-by-step way to set
up your channel the right way how to get
to your first 1000 subscribers and
beyond and to get access to our best
templates and downloads then you're
going to want to check out this offer
and then we'll be back for some more
reviews
did you see thinkmediasale.com
for the holidays we're giving you 80
off our brand new youtube made simple
course bundle
get over 1 900
worth of our best courses tools
templates and more just go to
thinkmediasale.com
all right well thank you so much for
being here for these channel reviews
today and we're going to jump into the
next one right now and that is with i
smell let me get yours up here and what
a cool channel name uh to even have
because you're you're doing colognes and
perfumes which i think is a really smart
idea um
one thing i want to point out right at
the beginning is that your thumbnails
are very bright it's awesome to see
really good thumbnails and you just
wanted a basic review just kind of a
critique of your channel so uh i would
say that because you're doing these
types of reviews um when we're doing
product review videos here at think
media you can actually just put the
products in the thumbnail so right here
this cologne i like how you did the
larger bottle and you're holding the
smaller bottle but really someone might
be coming to it wanting the actual
cologne and they don't know you yet they
don't know that you're the guy to help
them figure out the best smells and so i
would really actually work on doing more
product shot photography where you don't
actually have to be in the thumbnail let
the thumbnail sell the product not you
let the thumbnails sell the product so
that would be number one um number two i
see that you're you're doing a great job
with actually um hitting the different
types of fragrances that are out there
um and i like that you're doing uh you
know five so you're you're repurposing
content for your channel and when i came
down here
i was seeing that um i want you to be
working on these keywords here so even
when you are doing different types of
product reviews you can rather than just
putting in all these different like
school of scent all the different name
brands i want you to really be looking
at how you are doing your keywords five
fragrances guaranteed to make you stand
out that is actually the
uh keywords that you're going for i
would look at are people typing in the
word fragrances are people typing in the
word perfumes what words are people
using in their um titles and then uh
over here
i don't know your name i don't know if
you want to put your name out there but
you are building a brand on youtube so
it's always good to have you on youtube
and are you just selling online where
can i go if i want to buy a fragrance
where do i go i don't know where i
should go if i watched a video and i'm
excited about buying a fragrance uh
looking at your stats here i want you to
love that you did the four videos so
you're keeping consistent with that and
look you're up three thousand
subscribers so that is amazing um i
think this is a really good channel
you're just getting started you're you
started in june and i love the
consistency on your channel and i would
say you are doing a great
job i'm going to pass it over to tony
for the next review
amazing and our next channel we have
coming up here is uh named monzon media
and this channel the question that came
in said um any insight on retention for
tutorial channels uh doesn't matter what
i do retention average is usually 30
regardless of length people tend to get
what they need and then they're gone so
i do have some tips about this actually
um because we do have a
review channel here as well and so um
it's something i feel like we could
share on when it comes to our analytics
and in our back end here so when i look
at first your channel um it looks
amazing by the way so i'm gonna go off
the assumption there's some there's some
great production value happening here
it's not because you know you are
you have like you know really bad camera
really bad audio and that really can do
a lot for retention if you have bad
audio and it's painful to listen to
people are going to believe the video
faster than a fire on a building on fire
so um i just came up with that but
basically they're gonna leave they're
gonna leave the video really quick um if
you have bad audio bad lighting they
can't really see what you're doing um
but you you have a channel that doesn't
seem to have that problem um especially
with some of the you know crispiness you
have going on here um with your video
you can see right here just your camera
is brilliant amazing and even your hook
you have a little bit of before and
after happening here you're showing in
the first few seconds so having said all
that
here are some strategies that i can give
you with tutorial channels
the main one being that
um at the end of your video right at the
end of your video i don't want you to go
and say things like
all right so you learned everything you
need to know and that's
and and we're done and that's the end of
the video and kind of like in the
thought what i want you to think about
is towards the end of your video i want
you to open the loop to something else
um one of the videos that did this i
believe was this one we had a video that
was um netflix reveals the secrets to
getting more views on youtube and it was
all about um
it was all about like thumbnails and how
netflix uses thumbnails right
what happened was it goes at the end of
the video goes and that's what they do
with thumbnails but the important thing
with the thumbnails you have to have a
great title with it and we did a great
video on titles click on the end screen
right here well what happened was when
this video dropped this bump went up
like crazy here
because we actually sent it to another
video and opened another loop so that's
one of the ways you can increase your
retention is if you give people that
they don't really know that the video is
ending right is you just go okay and
then the fifth tip i have for you is you
got to get better titles and to get
better titles watch this video
because when you do that people just
continue to watch and binge in your
world now i will say everyone out there
who has a tutorial channel and a lot of
our a lot of people that think media
community here you have a tutorial
channel there is a realism of the fact
like this video did super well there's a
54
retention and so if you want to study
this video i really encourage you guys
to study this video for retention
because it's a great video how to write
a perfect youtube title that gets clicks
um we can probably link that in the chat
and i'll drop that in the chat in a
second
but you never want to end your tutorial
or even when you have the title of your
video and maybe it's like how to
accomplish
one thing right
i don't want you completing that answer
in two minutes and then have another
three to four minutes in your video
so it's getting into how can i give them
the ultimate satisfaction at the end of
the video and then end it quick right
after that whether i'm pointing into
another video or i'm landing the plane
right after i give them their complete
answer that's some tips for a tutorial
channel how you can increase that
retention 30 isn't too bad though
depending on how many video views you're
getting um but yeah if you want to bump
it up those are my couple tips for you
to do that and uh we're gonna jump to
the next channel and i'm gonna throw it
over to sean
yeah so we have will sko ted if you're
learning something today smash the like
button and uh that that tip that tony
just shared
is legit like really that we just showed
you with analytics verifiably that if
you really optimize the end of your
video you can reactivate old videos in
your library um doing that and
definitely if you're just joining check
out that replay and if you're getting
value share this out by the way if you
are acting the chat we're giving away
five copies of youtube secrets um uh
we'll be randomly selecting you and
letting you know in the chat and if
you're over on facebook watching this um
if you share because we're able to see
who shares the um stream you'll be
entered to win uh a couple of copies of
youtube secrets
and
the chances are pretty good because
there's not that many shares on that
stream over there so go ahead and do
that if you want to get a copy of the
book
um we have will skoda ted
first thing just to note is uh i love
that there's clarity on the channel
beginner and pro tools to help you win
at youtube now
i'm going to just kind of go bold on
coaching here and i want to thank you
for being a part of our community and
and really shouts you out too i think
you've been a part of tech week
every single stream i think you you're
part of the vra fam so grateful for you
um and again
like we want to speak the truth in love
and and really give you hard coaching
that can then help you grow
immediately i see canva i see snap but
it seems like you're going to share a
lot of design stuff
i'm going to be honest the cover image
doesn't feel like strong design to me
and some of the even logos are a little
low res
like i see that your thumbnails you know
from my viewpoint are very sharp and
crispy
but
i share that
because um it's kind of like most deaf
says my presence speaks volumes before i
say a word
like
your design
your channel layout
thumbnails our avatar they speak without
a say anything without us saying
anything
and so if you're going to position
yourself in pro design i just want to
challenge you to level up the design
now
design can be subjective and and clearly
you've got the skill set there but i'm
just asking you to evolve you know a
little bit and
ultimately i think you've got
it seems like it kind of feels like
multiple different fonts happening in
the cover it you know et cetera so so
saying all that again because you're
saying and this is for all of us
like we want to really if we're going to
say like
i am claiming to be a camera expert
i
really dig deep to learn as much as i
can about cameras and to really back up
not just
what i say but that that uh you know
the authority and the expertise and the
practice that it takes now i can see
like your thumbnails are looking sharp
they're you know you've got some more
sharpness so i'm just saying continue to
evolve the whole deal does that make
sense is that fair uh to to really back
up if you're gonna be if you're helping
people with pro design then bring that
pro design fire now you're also just
brand new clearly only three uploads
you're off to an incredibly great start
good niche uh
omar made the point earlier too i like
that you're using sentence case
so or title case make a free thumbnail
and it's clean here it's clean here but
it's all lowercase here
um which i suppose but even that's a
little bit of consistency i'm kind of
nitpicking here but i am challenging you
to just be world-class and excellent in
those details because you're coaching
others to be world-class and excellent
in the details
um
and uh and you've got some great views
though for the the first startup uh
start starting out here couple uploads
green like crazy i mean growth is
certainly happening uh like crazy 90
growth and views 500 growth in
subscribers brand new channel only three
uploads in you know i would encourage
uh again it's it's kind of pet peeve for
me here a little bit but like
this font versus this font versus
i i'm just i
take it for what it's worth uh is is
think about design design aesthetics or
or bringing a clear theme to the design
aesthetics but hear me too
you are i would say crushing it
in the meantime this just shows us the
power of like we're pursuing excellence
but we can experience growth on your
first three uploads there's people
watching that would just love to have 41
views on a video and you're already
getting those kind of uh results which
is cool and so um yeah i would say keep
it going and the power of the niche
you're in is that people want tutorials
on canva they want tutorials on uh on
these different things i think we got to
review your energy maybe it was inside a
vra and your energy on camera was great
your camera presence was great and so um
i know i've given some uh hard coaching
here but again generally in my opinion
you have all the ingredients
necessary to really just continue to get
one percent better with every upload and
um the niche you're in
i i think the future is incredibly
bright
in terms of growth just keep doubling
down and
i would love to see some tweaks to that
cover image though high resolution logos
consistent resolution across the board
consistent resolution of your photo and
your cutout
uh
like what's this little black little
what what why why why the sloppy design
here
right like just coming out from behind
the arm i'm saying that because i these
attention to details just matter and i
say that in love for all of us watching
like
don't over be overly critical of
yourself on the journey in terms of like
well i'm not good at design yet i don't
mean you i mean somebody else like i
don't even know how to design a cover
but i'm just saying like own it own the
excellence and that excellence is gonna
speak louder than even the words on our
titles or or our cover because it'll
just excellence talks good design talks
my presence speaks volumes before i say
a word
all right what's the next channel review
all right lisa these delights uh thanks
for uh tapping in lisa um i i from a
snapshot first um i think this is great
i love your your channel artwork uh it
says lisa d's delights by chef lisa d
and then southern cuisine cuisine with a
healthy flair cooking made simple for
beginners just like cool very easy to
read um and you've definitely chosen red
you know like red lipstick like
it's it's cohesive your face
you know with the chef hat and then
meets the nice little photo at the other
side so this is just a good
like in a snapshot i know i know what
her channel is about i know what she
looks like and and there's and there's a
vibe and feel uh and so and shout out to
the dog shitsu or picking these um
we got this chef chef tasting officer
but you did ask specifically uh the
overall quality of your channel look in
your videos and how to get retention
retention up and i'd like tony after i
share some things maybe speaking because
his wife does a vegan channel but
i would say um when it comes to food a
lot of the times
lighting is so important and so when i
when i look at your thumbnails uh it's
it's a little bit low on the lighting
side like it's it's dark and you don't
want food to be dark and dingy uh you
want food to be bright and and and
colorful and um and you want it to be
true and oftentimes you can actually
make food less enticing uh if it's just
not well lit right and so
you know this goes back to just
commercials and and you know they use
fake food sometimes for commercials and
stuff like that all because it needs to
look um attractive and wanting to click
on so with that being said i would say
uh to potentially invest into a cob
light
we push a light
called the gvm 100 watt
light kit
and it would be one light but it would
put off such a soft but large uh
light on your self but as well as on
your food and it would look more um
attractive i would in my
i wouldn't even say that's not in my
opinion that would just actually happen
so look at a cob light so you ask how do
you level up the quality of that so that
would level up your thumbnails and it
would also level up your videos because
that would be the light you would throw
on your uh the food
i would also say
this i mean i like i mean i like ham so
i clicked on this
mouth-watering cherry glaze baked ham
just like this
well
so
i know you kind of heard it a little bit
faint but
when you're doing tutorials or you're
showing people how to do something this
goes for anybody showing how to do
something on youtube
your best bet honestly is to actually
preview whatever it is you're gonna show
them and so for the first you know
portion of this video it's just
snapshots you with a tomato you with a
spatula you know blurry image cool and
your voice over but more than this you
should be you should be flashing some of
that you should be flashing some of that
you should be flashing and then like
boom and i'm going to show you how to
get to this and then you're like frick
man now i need to watch this video
because you showed me all these missing
you know these pieces not put together
yet therefore they would stay and watch
the video so that's kind of one way you
can level up your uh the quality and
feel of your videos is is simply by
by no pun intended but sauce your video
before you know people are gonna wash it
watch it
and because a lot of your video is a
voiceover
um or even you know talking head
investing in a decent lavalier mic um
it's a little bit uh loud when i was
watching a few of your videos in between
the last coach sesh uh but it definitely
looks like you are a subject matter
expert and you know what you're doing
and your food looks amazing and so
that's great and then the last thing i
want to say and then i'd love tony to
speak into it
is is sometimes your format is incorrect
when it comes to your upload format so
this looks like you were filming your
video
you know um with your with a vertical
iphone and i'll do like an actual an
actual example like this one so this is
so if you're trying to do a short you
actually have to upload a vertical video
in order for it to
show up as a short i
i don't think this is
uh last last attempt because i i found a
video like this one
like
like this one
nope
uh where was it i found it one of your
videos wasn't
horizontal and it was like black on the
sides
but i would just say
keep it white if you know it's wide and
then if you're doing a short to upload
vertical video but tony what would you
say to her stuff based off what you say
she reminds me of mary in our
community but i think with consistency
she can crush
yeah no i think a lot of what omar is
saying is really key i think the big
thing with cooking channels and my wife
has one so we and i've been in the
trenches with this a little bit is
you really have to
the two things you would have to master
is food photography like look up youtube
videos on how to shoot food photography
a lot of them will tell you the lights
that omar just said i have one of those
lights too
and the thing about it is um
that almost has to sell your food has to
look amazing in the thumbnail and even
in the hook at the beginning you gotta
like have mouth-watering shots
right you're gonna be showing the food
close-up and some of those things i'll
show you real quick um
in an example um so my wife's channel uh
this is something we did was we did a
vegan crunchwrap supreme so it kind of
starts with like oh this is what you're
gonna see some mouthwatering like things
you know things that are cooking and
you're seeing oh you're really gonna
learn how to make this crunchwrap
supreme
in the first year i'll make it a little
bigger for you guys to see it better but
you're gonna you know learn how to make
this thing and mouth-watering looks good
and that was some of the things that we
found was that the videos that had
really good food photography and started
off with like mouth-watering shots just
tended to do better in retention and you
know you can see some of her i'll just
make this bigger so we can see this some
of the thumbnails like you just start
getting a cleaner look just with what is
there
and
that's just some of the things we did is
we just really leveled up the food
photography
um spent in the time to really make the
food look appetizing you know like
whether it was these rolls mashed
potatoes even like our tutorials like
how to cut things we just try to make it
look very like appetizing and warm and
not too busy so that's what i would um
encourage you with awesome you got the
next one sauce god chaos
yeah so we got sauce god chaos here's
the question they have is are there any
improvements i can make um
my channel is sauce god chaos and i want
to start having a style for all my
videos like my recent videos um i also
have a separate channel for shorts
now so i guess my first tip would be
this
and um
i can also pull it up here as well omar
real quick
my first tip would be this that um
i don't know if i am i have a purveyor
of having a separate shorts channel and
the and the everyone here could disagree
with me and omar even could disagree
with me on this but
i feel like shorts are a great way to
bring people into your longer form
content and if you don't really have
longer format and you're just shorts
it becomes trickier to monetize that um
the audience also tends to be more
volatile and not as maybe loyal it's
just it's a harder way in my opinion
to build a strong true fan audience
that's going to be there and watch
multiple of your videos um so i would
say this that that would be the first
thing that i would just say about shorts
um and again that might that might be a
hot take on that but um you're also
asking about
you want to have a certain style for
your videos now if i look at sauce god
chaos obviously this looks like gaming
when i click into your about obviously
if you have this filled out
make apex legends content amazing as a
wraith main amazing so you really niche
down about which what kind of videos
you're making with in apex which i'm
familiar with this game and my brother
is a gamer so i'm very familiar with the
niche so here's what i would say
that a lot of your videos and i'm trying
to see right here here's a great example
right right in the front of the homepage
your uploads how a watson main gets
ready for season 11
buffs that are coming right this already
is a how-to video and it's a lot clearer
right where ash gives next level meta
vibes and sees an 11
it's not super clear to me you're not
giving me value and promising a value to
me and if i look at some of your most
popular videos i'm just curious on what
kind of content is working for you
already
obviously some shorts some shorts some
shorts some shorts which i think i said
you guessed you started a second channel
for shorts but you're also pushing
shorts here
um scrolling down scrolling down okay
the best champion console settings and
sensitivity
the best champion console settings for
xbox so your best settings your
tutorials for the people that are
playing the game i think you have
endless possibilities you could go um
how to get to masters right a journey to
the journey to masters how to get to
masters my 10 best tips for getting
there you know how to what's the best
loadout what's my best settings like all
those videos are going to be hits for
you because you're speaking to your 3.1
000 subscribers and you're going to be
giving them value first so when i look
at some of your newer videos it's not
that they're bad you know the not the
thumbnails are bad kind of interesting
you know you have some gaming stuff here
and it looks like you have some gaming
highlights that are happening here as
well
um i would just think through like what
kind of channel you want to be are you
going for entertainment based and
showing highlights of your live stream
or are you trying to be more educational
and lean into that because we believe
some of educational content is the best
way to get traction quickly
without having to be entertaining
because that skill
is very very challenging to develop and
very very few people accomplish that so
i would just encourage you to lean more
into tutorial content um if you can like
even how a watson main gets ready for
season 11 this is what i'm talking about
this kind of content here it's already
doing well for you and so i would look
at doing those things and that would be
my tip for you as a gaming channel um
i'm gonna pass it over to sean
with find tip creative studio
yeah hey if you're having fun on the
channel reviews today
uh go ahead and smash the like button we
have about 10 or so people in the queue
channel reviews are closed because we
want to get to everybody we are hustling
for another about 45 minutes for those
next channels um if you haven't checked
out the holiday sale we're doing at
thinkmediasale.com today's coffee with
channel is brought to you by
thinkmediasale.com check that out in the
description down below and stick with us
too and let us know in the comments
what's your biggest takeaway um i also i
see you sean and i see
uh ledrick taylor on uh on facebook
thanks for being here i see you miss
finance and gaming do and knee cars and
a free tv over on youtube let us know
what are you learning that you're going
to apply to your next youtube videos or
upgrading your channel even as you watch
other people's channels right there's so
much that we can learn so drop your
biggest aha moment um in the comments
wherever you're uh watching this live
stream we have fine tip creative studio
and um i'm gonna go straight for
something we can all learn about
potentially attracting the wrong
subscribers so i see this channel is
great i see it it's pretty clear where
it looks like a lot of um
kind of toys collectibles
a lot of it would seem maybe we have
like a father and son here i see the sun
in a lot of videos and that's strong but
what i noticed was when we go to most
popular video you did a great uh tour of
area 15 which is a cool spot out here in
vegas
and so you must be in vegas shout out to
shout out to the vegas locals here's the
problem this video by far continues to
get a lot of views for you now i don't
know if it's driving subscribers but
here's my thought
this video is gonna get you the wrong
subscribers picture this someone's
thinking about visiting area 15
they um they click subscribe because
they maybe want other vegas stuff or
other travel stuff and then more or less
the channel never follows up with that
so just something for you to consider
what can happen is we can fall in love
with the vanity metrics of our most
popular video and i want to ask
everybody a question
do you have a video
that is actually getting views and
growing your channel but it's growing
your channel with the wrong subscribers
do you have a video that's attracting
subscribers to your channel but the
content you're uploading now
those subscribers wouldn't be interested
in it something to consider because i'm
sure you're in love with that video it's
amazing it's so well done but this isn't
a this isn't a video tour channel yes
area 15 is creative but it's just so
different than funko advent calendar and
so i think you really have to consider
that when it comes to this you know
beyond that i think you're doing
phenomenal because
you're pumping out a ton of videos
go for green you got green you got
growth
i i get what it is i i do like the
thumbnails i think in some cases they're
a little busy because when you've got
the full
still good because spider-man is
outlined with the white there you know
that's nice um and uh i think that
you are having plenty of videos do
really well that do seem on brand
whether it's covering the right product
at the right time um in terms of the
majority of stuff
you know grinch christmas and disney
character hunt so i love all this
consider making this video
unlisted or being okay with the
consequences because the final thing
i'll say as we get ready for the next
channel review is this the problem with
wrong subscribers
is they're not going to click on your
new videos and by not clicking on your
new videos it's going to lower your
click-through rate
and when youtube tests distributing your
videos to your subscribers first and
they don't click on it it can truncate
the reach of the video
reaching farther beyond that which
ultimately you want growth you want to
get to 10 000 subs 100 000 subs so think
about dialing it in and try to never
upload videos that your subscribers
didn't subscribe for i noticed you did
you have a wildlife park driving walk
through
you have a utah parking walkthrough it's
just that seems a little different you
can do whatever you want because this is
youtube this is your
tube
but think about niching that down
because i do think you have a good thing
going with all these products and really
building up that momentum all right
let's hit the next one
all right i got the next one pulled up
but before we get into it we want to
give away um you know two
copies of this book right here youtube
secrets
and um we uh we want to pick two people
out of the comments and so i'm gonna
if
if you could in the comments put if you
can use this book maybe uh what your
youtube channel is about um
i think this guy did it without me
asking because it was a 11 18. i'm gonna
buick outdoors i have a chicken hunting
video and a chicken cleaning video that
generate a ton of views and i get quite
a few sums from it and probably that
they are seasonal oh my gosh this is
great because the next person i'm going
to be reviewing is going to have to tap
into this so buick outdoors we want to
send you youtube secrets uh and if you
want it in korean we can too as well uh
but if you just want the regular version
just uh
uh email us at giveaways seancannel.com
to get your book buick and then the next
person
i would like to pick
um
is uh let's see let's see
um
oh dang crypto mining here we got book
please
um
let's see let's see
oh yeah
i think i'm gonna i'm gonna hit this one
steve
drumheller today's tech life i'd love
the book
um today's tech live suite steve same
with you make sure you uh email
giveaways at seancannell.com
uh steve shout out to everybody we'll
we'll continue to give away more books
but let me get into this next channel
review and we have mel
just simple uh this is a halls decor uh
kind of channel where she just shows
different stuff for different things and
so but i wanted to
kind of talk about before i get into her
question it's you know her channel is a
trend surfing channel she's she's trend
she's riding the wave of seasons and so
if you see like
right you know in october we have all
the halloween stuff and then
and then we have a little bit of um
st patrick's day then we go into
valentine's day so this is like one
strategy we do encourage to fight figure
out how you can make a season work for
you and uh she has taken that you know
and and have done that and but her
concern was this is that her videos
would usually get five to six hundred
views and then she just recently took a
small break and now uh they're getting
just you know uh
about 50 to about 100 views and so a
little drop off when it comes to
viewership and so i would say the the
first thing is to not be discouraged
when when you see lower views um and
that's especially when understanding
what it is you're doing so
you know i may find your content helpful
just for the season of halloween but
like i don't need
you know fall decor like i'm moving on
to christmas but you put out a fall
decor video or thanksgiving and so like
because because people may just need you
for a season so understanding uh how
you're serving your audience is is is
that your audience might be a come and
go type audience because they just are
looking for help for that season and so
don't be too discouraged for that and
also because you are trend surfing i
would say the the strategy in trend
surfing is that you're riding the wave
of a season so like some of your videos
will get you know a burst of views and
then it'll completely die
uh when when that season comes your your
st patrick's day videos aren't going to
generate any views
during christmas time right
and so that's just something to think
about i think thinking about how you can
kind of in between these moments maybe
you want to tap into certain designs so
like you know you're talking through you
know different designs halloween decor
what about like something alongside
along the lines of like uh mid-century
modern decor ideas or you're tapping
into things that are more uh general uh
you know even um i'm a fan of like uh
like scandinavian design which is like
the ikea cleanliness modern uh type of
thing but that's kind of what i would
encourage you with is just like having
videos that kind of help in in between
those seasons
um and then and then i would encourage
you you wouldn't be as bummed about with
your views if you were making sales and
i know that you're probably working up
into it maybe but when i was clicking on
this video right here um i noticed that
like you're you're you're showing you're
you know you're giving people a haul of
like what you've purchased
um
and i go in the description and i don't
see any links to anything so like you've
helped me yes like now i know what to go
and buy when i go to ross or marshalls
but like you could get very similar like
items on amazon or etsy or something and
and then send people to buy similar
products and then i know you wouldn't
you would care less about views if you
started making the dough so that would
be my encouragement to you
to get more views
necessarily might not be the goal quite
necessarily it's finding out ways to
create videos that can go
in between those seasons and as well as
getting an affiliate program so that
your videos can work for you when they
are actually working which they do when
you drop them so i just want to
encourage you with that and so with that
we'll pass it to the next um reviewer
which will be i believe tony let's run
it tony you got this awesome uh yes the
next channel we have coming up here is
cecily
dion dione i'm hopefully i'm pronouncing
that correctly um this channel is uh the
question really is i'm trying to get
more consistent but i'm struggling with
niching down let me know in the chat if
that's you too you're struggling with
consistency and niching down i'm a music
artist for artist for context let's see
the channel here so the channel here is
cecily dion like i said and there's a 20
21 fragrance review which doesn't seem
like music but i could could be wrong on
that and then tori kelly souls anthem
so i guess my main question for you is
this okay
right now it looks like you're about you
know one two three by six eighteen you
have 22 videos right now
um and if you look at your videos you're
kind of experimenting now you look like
you're trying different types of content
you're trying behind the scenes photo
shoot you're trying covers here's my
question for you
what do you want to be known for
what do you want to be known for
maybe you're like only known for my
singing okay well then you probably want
to lean into a niche in a in a
positioning in your channel that's going
to help set you up for being known for
your singing how could you do that well
one of the strategies is you could do
what you're doing out you're covering
songs you're like trying to lean into
trending topics um but the other thing
you could do is you could help other
people sing and
people that are fans of singers are
typically can be other singers you know
some of the biggest super fans of
musical artists are musicians themselves
and so what i would look at doing is you
know again if you want to be known for
just the singing
it's easier to be known for one thing
first before you transfer into something
else but if you try to get known for
multiple things at the same time it can
be quite challenging so i'm gonna assume
you're gonna say singing if you say
singing i would say this how could you
lean more into trending topics trending
songs and not only like just cover them
but could you educate other singers on
how to sing those songs because those
are what people are coming to youtube
for they're looking for a problem
now if you're like tony i don't want to
teach people i want to just be known for
singing and be an amazing singer
and just do covers and sing all of my
own original material you can do that
again like sean said it's your tube i
just believe that that's going to be a
slower way to get traction or a harder
way to break through
because if you have purely just an
entertainment channel you are not only
competing against other youtube channels
i mean on the youtube homepage i just
saw if i wanted entertainment i could
get a movie i could buy a movie right
there on youtube i could watch tv shows
i could watch things that i already know
and love i could watch netflix you're
competing with all those things and it
can become more challenging to stand out
not impossible but that would be my my
question for you my power question is
what do you want to be known for and
then lean into niching your channel in a
way that will get you known for that one
thing and you're in the experimental
phase so i want to just encourage you
keep experimenting keep trying because
you might find some other types of
content you like to produce and you're
really in those early stages it probably
doesn't feel like you're in this early
stages you've made a lot of you know
you've made like 22 videos i think it
was it feels like it's a lot but 22 on
the road to 500 or a thousand you're
still really in your prologue of your
youtube creation so continue to create
content continue experiment and go
towards the content that really you
enjoy and you want to be known for
that's going to help you be more
consistent because the more you enjoy it
or the more you're just motivated by
your why and why you're creating content
you're going to find yourself being more
consistent on youtube that's my best
tips for you with moving forward with
your channel sean
sean cannell here with the coffee with
cannell show on the think media podcast
channel with think media team
omar tony and heather and we are doing
channel reviews channel reviews are
closed we um have a bunch in the queue
we're going to keep smashing through
them next up we have lord heck
gaming and lord heck also has a larger
dance channel it seems uh this channel
is crushing at 1.6 million views in a
month 15 000 subscribers just growth in
this last month with 14 uploads but the
question is about the gaming channel i
need some pointers on the channel
lord hex squad i'm having a hard time
putting energy into the right kind of
content
that are not too competitive since i
have a rather small channel so what's
interesting to me is my initial question
is
why
are you
trying to grow a second channel when you
have such a successful primary channel
now it's your tube you can do what you
want of course i think you probably love
gaming it's it's a it's a fun outlet and
and even something maybe you want to
grow as well but we
have learned at think media that if you
try and chase two rabbits
sometimes you end up catching neither of
them or
in your case i mean you're doing well on
both channels in my opinion one channel
is absolutely crushing it so if you try
and chase two rabbits you just loose
dilute your focus
and your energy you know you're out here
saying uh i hope this channel grows but
you're up four thousand
forty-one percent in terms of views in
the last month 20 uploads so you're
hustling here and you're hustling on the
other channel it would be no surprise to
me if you felt a little exhausted and
let's see that
i don't know where those new views are
coming from but maybe 12
k from this
call of duty on mobile some of just the
last four weeks three weeks and even
month have gotten some breakout videos
so i see a lot of growth here so i mean
i think the biggest
you know
your smaller channel just might take it
needs time
um and you and you're hustling for sure
but again what i want to challenge you
with and challenge all of us with is
um what is it you want to happen
uh like and and
we don't have to get like overly
philosophical about it do you are you
trying to monetize in a more significant
way so you need more views to make ad
revenue are you trying to hit a
financial target
do you
do you legit want to have
two different silver play buttons is
your goal to get as many channels over a
hundred thousand you know what i mean
like what is it you actually want to
happen why why the multiple channels and
i know you might look at
you know all kinds of big creators
sometimes they have a video podcast and
a gaming channel and their vlog channel
and their main channel uh but man
dividing dividing our focus can really
imagine if we took all of our energy and
you focused it on your dance channel you
could probably grow it even more it
would be probably easier to get your
lord heck
channel from 300 000 subscribers to 500
000 than it will be to get your gaming
channel over a hundred thousand
but from the skills you've already
deployed i think you have the chance
um
to actually
do whatever you want the key is to get
clear on what is it you actually want
what is it you're willing to sacrifice
and it takes discipline and i think a
lot of us with better multi-passionate
as we get ready for the next channel
review
is
that we
it takes discipline to not do things so
that we can focus our energy on the
things that matter most i have a
personal channel called my sean cannell
channel i haven't uploaded it in months
i think about it probably every day i
think about what i want to talk about
there the videos i want to post it
literally i think about it every day so
hear me the heart of a creative the
heart of a creator
is is there's a lot of other things i
want to do but sometimes if you want to
have your most powerful 2022 think media
podcast crew wherever you're watching
this lean in for this
if you want to have your best
year next year
lean into the power of focus try to do
less better and i just think you'll
create a lot more momentum
and as you get more momentum last thing
lord heck if money is coming in hire
some people
lean into leadership a little bit lean
into some delegation a little bit
because the way you can do more healthy
is you get enough revenue money for the
mission to be able to share the work i
don't know if you have to edit or what
you have to you can do the dancing
channel and the gaming channel
potentially if you maybe delegate some
of the other tasks you're doing and that
could help you go further faster i it
doesn't seem like you have a lack of
energy because it looks like we're
pretty much uploading daily between the
14 dance videos and the 20 gaming videos
or whatever so there's a ton of hustle
coming out i respect that but think
about dialing in that focus and rather
than being a shotgun
be a laser
and i think you'll make greater impact
and see the growth you're after all
right let's hit the next channel
all right and i love that lord heck said
you really appreciate that review sean
thank you so much for that power of
focus power of focus that is what we
need going into this next
season and i'm gonna do uh the sensory
strut and i'm really excited to review
this channel um because i love that
she's bringing awareness uh to families
that have um children with special needs
and i think it's such an underserved
community on youtube so i want to
congratulate you for stepping out i read
your bio and it said you've been uh
helping families for the last six years
so i'm so excited that your journey is
now on
youtube and a couple things you asked
about your titles and thumbnails um i
think that you are doing an okay job
with your titling uh but i think we need
to also do the power of focus here as
well if you're helping families with
sensory issues with non-verbal
communication with autism with different
types of special needs throwing in
videos about your weight loss journey is
counterintuitive to the type of audience
that you're trying to reach just because
someone's interested in special needs
does not mean that they're interested in
your personal weight loss journey while
i want to applaud you and say
come on with losing that first 100
pounds that's amazing let's keep that
journey actually out of the youtube
sphere for right now or put it on a
separate channel where you're just
uploading when you can but i want you to
be focusing on this uh topic that you
have your channel about and here's a
hack for you uh when it comes to when i
looked at some of your videos that are
performing really well around that topic
155 views um to a non-verbal child and
then even down here with using
us
special needs families um here's a hack
all right so lean in if you're still
here watching the stream with me thank
you so much i want to show you this if i
were to put in uh let's say sensory
um uh sensory what was the word sensory
sounds uh where were you at here um
let's go and do non-verbal or sensory
uh
a if i do sensory a autism sensory
activities for toddlers sensory s
asmr sensory activities for babies okay
now what if i actually just went autism
um if that is who you're helping maybe
that's who you're helping so autism a
and then it's going to bring up all
these different types autism awareness
autism and relationships how about
autism toddler
autism toddler learning videos autism
toddler speech therapy autism toddler
therapy
autism toddler talking are you seeing
the power of what you can do
when you just go after the key words of
what people are searching for let's put
a space before and see what happens
fathering with autism maybe you
interview a dad uh maybe there is um
toddler let's put
toddler autism a toddler with autism
signs
toddler with autism talking so are you
seeing the power of the amount of videos
you could be doing on this channel uh
the sensory strut you have a lot of
amazing opportunities to reach families
and help them in a lot of different ways
what are the tools that they need what
are the uh what are the um different uh
pieces of um of toys and things like
that that they need in their homes as
they are raising a child who has
different abilities i hope that helps
you and we're gonna pass it to the next
one which is sean
yeah next up is duck finder and uh this
channel
is an entertainment channel a lot of
energy on here with the voiceover uh
leaning into fair use in fact if you're
here live i hope for your channel review
um you can let us know if you have any
challenges with fair use see a lot of
people watching i'm sure you maybe
um didn't realize that if you are making
transformative content what he's doing
is he's putting a voice over all these
clips and these still images
and doing um content around you know
popular topics like the eternals and
things like that i think that uh on the
one hand
uh let me see specifically if there was
a question related to this and i think
i don't know um and uh
the um
we are seeing growth we are seeing uh
there was no question cool so uh go for
green i mean subscribers are up a little
bit five new ones celebrate celebrate
the win three uploads i definitely see
your videos are challenging to make
because you pull a lot of footage you
write a script or deliver a lot of
energy on on the voiceover but views are
up and so
your your the strategy appears to be
it's clearly
going for that kind of viral
going for that suggested videos going
for that trending moment when you get
you know click-through rate and the
truth is in a niche like this
you can have a breakout video in fact
tony just had a breakout but he has a
faceless channel and he had a video
related to game of thrones that's just
going viral it's just boom and it's it's
it's old too it's hundreds of days old
so
part of this strategy is just sticking
with it you've been in here for 10
months
uh and so it's you
there's a lot of competition on some of
these popular topics but you keep
hustling you might have that breakout
video um the next thought is is just
talking about the right thing at the
right time what you're definitely after
you're reacting to some squid game stuff
here or you're reacting to someone
reacting to squid games on shorts and so
i would say keep going the edit's good
the voiceover's good the energy's good
um i think that the right topic at the
right time with the right title uh could
be definitely what it is and um there is
a ton of opportunity in this niche um
but
there's also a lot of competition so
keep looking for those angles and those
ways to maybe you know
jump on jump on something new jump on a
show first
you know
we had a great video for squid games
related to think media but first of all
there's the actual hustle to create it
and second of all the idea came to us
about two weeks after the initial boost
of the trend so for everybody watching
when you're trying to surf trends speed
matters sometimes it's time to crush a
red bull and pull an all-nighter to get
your video out related if you can be
first and quality
it could be your breakout moment duck
finder oh i mean all you need is a video
that starts just like oh i love this guy
you hit a thousand subs ten thousand
subs one video starts activating the
rest of your library so i encourage the
perseverance and i'm going to pass the
mic to the next channel review all right
i'm pumped for this one this is natalie
heels natalie heels a newer channel and
i it's always cool to see new channels
with like clean design i would even
actually argue it takes like
just a day maybe a weekend to like dial
in your channel's look and feel and vibe
and that's you know description and
about and things like that um i would
say like one
might as well use the the tools that you
have
so just as first let me talk about like
just the channel page
when you're at the home page uh number
one there's no there's no links i mean
like youtube lets you have links put
links here whether it's social media
whether it's your best recommended
products or you know maybe deeper corset
maybe you have deeper trainings or
that's something you'd like to do throw
them up here
and
i do see that you only showcase your
shorts which i know they're getting some
views which is awesome that your your
shorts are getting views
but i would uh encourage you to also put
your your your most proud work here like
what tony mentioned a bit ago in this
stream was about putting videos that you
think a new person would benefit from if
they just landed on this
um and so yeah definitely want your
videos here i mean i do i think i think
i think choosing a video as your channel
trailer or just genuinely making one
it because like i'm choosing who i'm
gonna stretch with you know and like if
i land on your channel somehow maybe
through a short it'd be nice to see your
face and you introduce yourself maybe
you know maybe an authority line like i
you know i i've been doing this for this
long and i like helping people you know
whatever help with back stress neck pain
so i do see that like you have a
cohesive design when it comes to your
thumbnails which is great uh so keep
that up um
just some things i noticed
is like again uh if like i'm just saying
like if i had to pick one if it was this
one or if it was this one which one
would it be like
and like this is more clear not only
because the color you know emphasis but
also it's it's bigger like the person is
bigger and i know this is you but like
i don't you know it's just you're very
small i unless it like has to have a
full body in it uh i think the only way
you can really get by with full body
thumbnails is if you have super great
compression when it comes to uh your
photography and stuff but that's just
for the most part these are working like
you know i love to see like this one
this could have been your whole body but
you chose you know to have a piece of
like a hip which is super great so i
want to encourage you to keep this up
right here like the the up close thing
and anything that you can do to even
point more attention to like a pain
point whether it be a color or an arrow
or something like that um i i want to
encourage you with and i know you're
probably working on it but like you make
up amazon black friday thing and you
uploaded a time lapse
about you using this stuff and then like
i'm like cool but then it's like i mean
you don't have it you don't have it yet
the amazon affiliate program which is
fine but i would say how does this video
every every video is an opportunity to
educate the people who know you about
what your video your channel is about
and i think this
this could have been maybe
a different use of
uh your content creation time um and
then the last thing i want to encourage
you with is to really harp on i think
you're i think with this kind of stuff
stretching and pain relieving is
definitely doing uh time time
stamped or time sensitive videos 15
minute this that 30 minute this or that
one hour this or that and and really go
go for those and and over time
you will have a channel where you have a
library of videos that can help with
neck pain back pain hip pain but
multiple things that can help and i
think that will be a good use of your
time as you move forward and create more
content continue to do your shorts
because it seems like they're doing well
because and i think it's because if i
learn about a stretch while i'm like on
youtube shorts that it's going to
benefit me that i've never seen before
then it's probably going to be favored
and so i see that but i would encourage
you with that to definitely level up uh
on on the time frame workouts and
stretches
as opposed to
you know just general things you kind of
did that here five minute fix uh five
minute fix five day full body um but
like there's a lot of title help that
you can um you know
do there a lot of the people that we are
actually helping today need some title
help what is somewhere people can go
uh
sean where they can get title help maybe
we got something going on this holiday
season that can help with that
yeah omar uh
titles are make will make a huge
difference as will you know if you're
taking notes or thinking about your plan
for 2022 topics actually is going to be
your biggest thing then titles then
thumbnails and then following it up with
strong content and if you haven't heard
yet or you're just joining we
have a 80 off cyber week sale happening
at thinkmediasale.com
and included in that bundle is our
youtube starter kit and that has our 15
title templates so there's downloads in
that starter kit it also has a list of
51 video ideas to boost you on that side
and it'll help you on the thumbnail side
as well so check this out and then we're
going to hit the next channel review did
you see
thinkmediasale.com
for the holidays we're giving you 80
off our brand new youtube made simple
course bundle get over 1
900
worth of our best courses tools
templates and more just go to
thinkmediasale.com
yeah fired up and that is happening at
thinkmediasale.com you can see all the
details and that's limited so get the
discount why if you're if you're going
to take youtube serious in 2022 this
could be one of the best investments you
can make and i mean that i mean we we
it's backed by a whole risk free
guarantee because you're absolutely
going to love this program and it's
going to push you to a thousand
subscribers and beyond so uh
thinkmediasale.com check it out and
let's kick it over to tony for the next
shower review
amazing and right before i get into that
channel review i'm actually going to
pick two people to win a youtube secret
books youtube secrets book
in the chat and so i want to pick
martica sherman i want to win the copy
youtube secrets having golden nuggets to
exist assist me with building my channel
is always a plus i know this book will
help me it will help you because it's
coming your way
and again if you got picked as a winner
anytime in the stream for a giveaway
like this email giveaways at
seancannell.com but martika sherman i
hope you uh enjoy the youtube secret
book the next one that i'm going to give
out one more
round and round i go where i stop nobody
knows okay we are stopping on
phillips sport sportsman philly sports
mom would like a book planning to create
top trending instructional available uh
instructional available maximize your
human potential there's a lot going on
there but i hope to help you with this
youtube secrets book and again email
giveaways at seancandle.com
to get that giveaway um sent to you
and so we're going to jump into the next
channel review um this next channel is
joe mcflow that's kind of an awesome
name honestly joe mcflow all right
and the only question was just first
impressions and so i'm gonna just tell
my first impressions uh joe mcfloat 15
subscribers just starting out like you
said stadia news games and tips
now here's the thing i'm gonna throw at
you right away
the stadia
is not the safest bet when it comes to
making content for console gaming or for
gaming in general
reason i say that it's not proven it's
kind of volatile and it's not really
gaining traction um in the gaming
community like it hopes it hoped it
would
so here's all that to say is this not
that you can't make stadia content
but i would encourage you to make your
channel a little bit wider maybe of a
niche than just the stadia
maybe it's console gaming um or maybe
you you go into xbox nintendo or
playstation or sony that already has a
really thriving
audience
and again this is my personal opinion
about the stadia i just don't see it as
that thing you could probably build a
whole channel and monetize it around
it's very
it's very unproven and again i don't
they could cancel it tomorrow um gaming
platforms do that all the time
they'll start a whole thing and then
they thought it was gonna be bigger than
it was and
it crashed and so the stadium has the
potential to be that um it looks like
you do have some other content though
you do have to actually know you are
mostly all stadia
and so i guess i would encourage you
though but if you want to go deep on
stadia it's not that you can't make
content on it i just wouldn't base your
whole channel on it because it's like
putting your entire eggs in one basket
of
a platform that's unproven
doesn't have a critical mass meaning
like it's not really proven that you
could do a full-time income on it now if
you're like tony i just want to create
fun videos and i'm just doing this as a
hobby about this idea go for it but if
your ambitions is to have a full
full-time
huge like you know youtube business
channel really all around the stadium
and monetizing that and having a
full-time income you might need to widen
your niche that would be my first
impressions of your channel again
awesome you're taking actions love your
posting videos and um that would be my
tips for you
i will pass it over to the next review
which will be omar or nobishon sorry
sean bringing you on the screen yes sir
we are talking about immersive
sports science
um and a couple tips for you right off
the bat so i see your professional you
graduated cardiff in sports science
sports psychology you got degrees
and after clicking around on the channel
i seemed
that maybe you want this to drive a
business result because i could come to
your facebook page and i could click
call now
and actually give you a call and do
business with you
so
my
initial tip for you here and we'll talk
about the content really quick on the
channel but
is um
is consider the viewer experience for
your entire entire business and remember
think media podcasts like
especially if you want to drive a
business result and all of us if you
want to go full time on youtube you
should be thinking about what is my
business model how is it that i monetize
if you are more of a business-based
channel by getting people on the phone
or getting them to fill out a form is
the way that people could do business
with you consider their entire
experience
and one of the things that is kind of
just confusing is notice this it says
subscribe there's an arrow it points to
facebook
subscribes over here now of course
resolution changes and different things
so that's a viewer experience thing
but i'm also not a huge fan of sending
this to facebook
because now i'm here and i might see
call but i don't know why i should call
and now i have to look at other things
and think about the viewer journey it's
kind of confusing because now i'm like
okay i was here why would i even want to
go there fb well there's already a
facebook logo so
adam mpt and performance consider
what does that even mean like should i
you know okay is that your name
like
click here and give us a but here's what
i'm tip number two is remove steps
eliminate steps so whatever what is the
result or where would you want people to
go now a lot of cases maybe your
business model if you're watching this
is to get as many views as possible so
your actual goal is to have people never
leave youtube
but maybe you want to collect email
addresses or collect
like
give me some words that tell me where to
go and don't send me to facebook so i
can click the call thing
send me directly to a simple page that
drives the one result that you want
people to do that'll move the needle in
your business and i wanted to share that
because i think that could practically
help you get more leads drive more sales
or you know get more people uh
calling you and doing coaching with you
or whatever it is you actually do
specifically
but all of us could benefit from that
tip additionally next is it seems like
a lot of these are kind of reaction
videos it looks like you yeah you
reacted to the lance armstrong video
uh it would seem
and it played a lot of clips here
okay
maybe you're summarizing that there
uh but but
part of my thing was it was kind of hard
to find a cohesion in the content like
it just seemed like a lot of
compilations i mean okay
um and
i mean my thought is
this is kind of two questions i have we
don't have enough time to go into i
suppose the answer you you could ask
yourself the answer um
this
i know dislikes are going away but and
maybe because it was controversial but
it looks like it was almost like a 50
dislikes
again if you have a polarizing opinion i
think that's that's cool that's fine but
but dislikes can be a signal if we if we
write out that they're trolls or we
write out that it's just maybe a
divisive area
is it
is maybe just worth asking yourself you
know
what's going on here because you have
some very high view videos so that's 31
000 views 21 25 000 8.5 000
uh but some of these
are are very disliked it might not be
bad because it doesn't mean you need to
be liked by everybody but it is an
indicator of how do i create content
that really resonates and then um you
know creates a positive user for your
experience and helps me grow
uh and
yeah i mean other than that i would also
think
final f tip would be
think about the structure of your videos
and and this is on the business side of
things
um
weave in a call to action to your videos
maybe it's at the very end
but in terms
in terms of the cadence of the video i
think you could drive more business
results
under the assumption that that's what
you're after i like that we have
affiliate links here i'm seeing that
that's cool
got some references so you're definitely
doing like thorough commentative
documentaries i see that's great
um but i'm just wondering i just all
that is coming from me trying to make
sense of you know what is it you want to
happen what is winning look like
and if you want people to come here and
call you
then um i would love to see that link in
the description down below and then
final thing for all of us let's sum it
up we'll do the next channel review
lay out the whole customer journey if
you've never done this and maybe you've
never used that language lay out the
whole viewer journey
what is it
if you are an entertainment channel the
whole viewer journey would be
get someone to click get them watching
videos get them to watch more videos and
keep them in a continuous loop of
watching your videos like a character in
wall-e that is actually plugged into a
machine ready player one that's just
watching videos on repeat on your
channel because then you'd have endless
traffic and endless money
this is the business model
now if it's business-minded
get people watching videos connect with
them you know add add value first
give and then ask and give an invitation
and say you know hey
i hope you got value of this video do
you want you know check out resources in
the description below just what is it
you want to happen some homework would
be to draw that out even on paper or to
kind of map that out with some digital
software
and then clean up the channel maybe so
that your and then consider what videos
would attract if this person over here
should call me
that could be a client for me
sometimes it might not even be about
views it's about getting the amount of
views it's about getting the right views
of clients in a particular local area
potential clients that could then
reach out and
um
learn from you see that you know your
stuff see that you know your sports
science and then ultimately fill out a
form or get on the phone with you so i
hope that adds value and let's uh pass
the mic to omar
all right all right uh yeah pumped for
this this is rhys black
um game swag purpose life he put when he
did the super chat um
i appreciate the feedback if possible in
the niche of entertainment and uh uh
social entertainment of dating
relationships only difference is i'm
married i'm a married family man that
speaks on what men are thinking
um i would i would
i definitely get that uh vibe based off
of like some of the videos i watched um
that you're trying to help men so i
think your your niche is is helping men
be more confident you know your niche is
helping men date better uh
and and
knowing where you're coming from i don't
know your background and authority but
there's so much to like when you are
helping
and coaching guys in this manner or even
if you're a woman you know coach that
helps girls and ladies
then i would encourage you to really
you gotta look professional you gotta
you gotta convince me that i need to
listen to you
and a lot of that comes with excellence
uh if you're trying to help somebody but
your stuff doesn't looks like you it
needs help then it's going to be hard to
uh receive from you and so i i mean
starting with like just the channel i
know you're you know it's it's it's not
all
um it seems like it's like not the
priority
uh in regards to like certain things
like
you know empty empty channel
homepage so i would encourage you to put
some uh videos that you think would help
the person so back to what sean just
said think about who it is you're trying
to help and then what does their journey
look like well their journey looks like
they're trying to see how you know how
they can be more confident and asking
girls out and that they would find this
library of videos in regards to that and
then they would watch my content and
then maybe take this quiz
that's a free quiz that lets them know
about something and you get their
information and then maybe you can coach
them you know one-on-one or help them or
maybe produce courses later on but i say
all that to say thinking through what it
is so back to the excellence factor um
this is a most recent upload and so like
this is your set and like you know we
usually we're we're talking like
strategy on like the the thumbnails and
the titles and stuff because that's so
important um uh i would say though in a
in a niche like yours your your setup
kind of has to communicate who it is
you're trying to help and so when i see
this setup i think you're an rmb
music recording artist that's in your
sound booth and that might not even be
the case like you might just this might
be the cleanest shot that you can create
i think there is something about having
a setup that's inviting that makes
people at a snapshot
tell me why i should listen to you you
know essentially and then on on another
um practical side note starting with
your logo on your videos
uh is not the best you know way to start
start with like what people are going to
get into you know you only have so much
time to win somebody's attention
and you know just even in 15 seconds
here you haven't delivered any value and
i think there's something about knowing
how to create value-based hooks and
reeling in the viewer even once they
click so i mean i i just encourage you
to think through your setup maybe make
it more a little bit more inviting and
then um
finding a look on canva that you want to
run with i get you like black white and
red
um but stuff that there will be more
cohesiveness so maybe find find a coach
that you like on youtube it doesn't have
to be the same kind of coach obviously
you don't want to look exactly like
somebody but find somebody's vibe that
you're like i can connect with this vibe
there's red here the the the type of
thumbnails
and then based off of what is performing
best
it looks like the thumbnails with your
face in them perform best um and so i
just want to encourage you with that and
those are some things i would encourage
you to work on
um passing it right over
then to um
sean you want to give away some books
yeah
hey y'all we're in rally mode we got a
couple more channels to go smash like if
you've been getting value
shout out to the youtube crew where are
you watching from and we got about i
think about four more channels to review
um channel reviews are closed thank you
for being here y'all but we got a lot
more tips to share
shout out randall thanks for being here
good to see john over on facebook and
brandon on facebook in fact
on facebook um we are doing some books
book giveaways of youtube
secrets um if you haven't uh read
youtube secrets yet it's on amazon my
friend benji and i wrote it and uh it's
the best-selling youtube strategy book
in the world grateful
and um
to on facebook if you share out the
stream you'll be entered to win in fact
brandon jackson
uh gonna send you a copy of youtube
secrets email giveaways at
seancannell.com to claim that thank you
so much for sharing the stream and then
uh ashley mcdonald
shared out the stream and said any of my
friends who are thinking of creating a
youtube channel in 2022 check out this
live email giveaways at seancandle.com
congratulations you want a copy of
youtube
secrets all right we are gonna keep
things moving
um we're sipping coffee we're hustling
we're rocking and next up is tony with
victor the rookie card specialist
yes victor rookie card specialist and
i'm really excited about this channel
because it's a video it seems to be a
video podcast channel um which is pretty
cool because we talk about video
podcasts all the time here and it's
victor the rookie card specialist and
you can correct me if i'm wrong victory
for the chat but it seems to be a
podcast set up you have episodes at the
beginning of every video and you seem to
be sitting down for a lot of them and
talking like in a podcast fashion
now here's what i would encourage you my
initial just first thoughts one
great niche great positioning of channel
i think this niche has proven to be
profitable has a huge fan base already
you're tapping into that you're not
creating something that doesn't already
exist
here's what i would say though is that
if you are doing a video podcast and
you're also doing audio some of the ways
you've titled your
episodes
might work great on an audio podcast
but for a video podcast on youtube we
just find viewer behaviors a little bit
different and we know this because on
this channel
this channel you're watching this on
right now if you're on youtube right now
watching this this is our podcast
youtube channel
and i would encourage you to look at how
we do our podcast we've had you know
pretty pretty pretty good success on
this channel with getting great views
and also just great engagement from
people and the way we tend to do in our
strategy is
we title them kind of like a youtube
video um and what the value is of the
channel um and of the video really and
so when i would look at some of yours
like um
for example derek jeter rookie run with
rookie card exercises
and maybe because i'm just not in the
niche
i'm not sure if like the basic person
understands what that is right i would
look at potentially titling it you know
in a way where if you're showing all the
different derek jeter rookie cards
i think you would i would title it you
know um
derek jeter rookie card values
and how to know if it's fake right you
can talk about all these people trying
to fake it by this or this is not a real
one and maybe that's the value they're
gonna get from your podcast episode okay
and then the second thing i would say is
this
i'm just a huge fan i've been saying
this this entire stream that if you're
doing a podcast and it's longer form
content you know maybe like some of your
20 minute episodes you were doing or 8
17 minutes or you know 18 minutes 20
minutes
what could you
like chopped out of that and make it
into like a smaller piece of content
because those smaller pieces of content
sometimes will actually get you more
views and bring in traffic to your
bigger long form podcast now we see this
all the time on youtube i mean
the classic example we talked about is
joe rogan right like i don't know if
i've actually watched an entire three
hour joe rogan podcast but i've seen the
clips of like him with kanye him with
elon musk him with all these people
because they have these interesting
entertaining clips that are cut out i
would think about trying to look at your
content the same way because those clips
might actually bring people into your
longer form content
you know even chicago sports spectacular
vlog style
i would go okay chicago sports
spectacular tour
best deals i found or best deals to find
again it kind of gives me a little bit
of value of like oh i want to see what
were some of the good deals there
especially if i'm a super fan of this of
like you know sports card collecting and
stuff like that i want to see what some
of the best deals are there um and then
is it worth it you could also review the
event um and then i think a great way to
even monetize your thing is to maybe get
in touch with some of those events maybe
they'll let you come for free and review
it maybe they'll actually give you an
affiliate link to like promote that
event before going there and so those
are some of the thoughts i had of your
initial channel review again you're in a
great niche and if anything you're
having success you're at 408 subscribers
and you maybe aren't growing at the
speed you want to grow but you're
getting more views or growing views over
you know 55 views over the previous
month so i think a lot of it comes down
to continuing to be consistent the
things i'm telling you should not cause
you to paralyze yourself keep doing what
you're doing just make these little
tweaks try a different title try a
different style of thumbnail and see if
that starts to give you a little bit
more of an edge and just know that
podcasts
if you title them the way you can you're
titling them right now
they tend to not get as much traction on
youtube that's my first reactions great
channel great niche and continue going
what you're doing um you have a lot of
great stuff ahead again it's a great
channel smart idea so i'm gonna pass
over to heather for our next review
heather
torres
thanks tony about just been in the back
end chatting with you guys uh over in
the stream it's in the chat it's been
amazing thank you so much for being a
part of what we're doing here at think
media i have a channel review
and it looks like uh coming in from
missouri i saw that ebm scholars is uh
with us and can i say congratulations on
growing this channel 86 000 subscribers
and you really asked you said you want
to start doing this full-time and use
youtube as your main income how do i
take it to the next
level really great question and you know
i see here
when i looked at your stats uh that we
um you got you're publishing a lot of
content um at one time and so i would
actually go quality versus quantity um
for what you're doing i see you're
streaming you're posting
so you're doing a lot of content at one
time and when i look at what content is
really taking off um i saw in the about
that you are doing uh immigration
scholarships self-publishing books jobs
internships weight loss success i want
to i want to just encourage you again to
go back and focus what do you want to be
known for i know you're helping with a
lot of things but if you want to do this
full time then we have to figure out
what are you known for so we can get a
buy button for people to purchase
being a full-time youtuber isn't just
the income off of your views becoming a
full-time youtuber is creating a
business around your youtube channel and
that's what you're asking to do and so i
want to encourage you to pick one pick
one and really even with the immigration
and the scholarships you know you're
talking really about the green cards and
coming uh
coming into america going to school in
america getting married in america all
those types of things and uh when i was
clicking around you know i'm seeing here
like best tripod stand not your niche
not who you're trying to serve marriage
based green card discussion that's more
who you're trying to serve because when
i go to your most popular videos it is
green card lottery form from two years
ago green card lottery form green card
green card are you seeing a trend here
of what is happening
and so uh how can you make this an
actual business um i would say that
right now doing channel memberships
probably isn't going to get you to full
time quickly it is a way to become
full-time but i don't think that's going
to be your best bet i would be thinking
about what does it look like to work
with you maybe you have some way that
you can go deeper and i see here again
channel memberships but what are you
offering for the person to join that
membership and then when i click on your
links this came up here and i was like
oh he has a store so let me click on the
store
store doesn't exist so i need you to get
a buy button on your website get a buy
button on your youtube channel and
figure out what that is and uh right now
when you go to uh think media sale dot
com
when you go to this here you're gonna
get access to the youtube made simple
course uh you can uh it's 80 off right
now and when you do that you're actually
going to get uh the seven money
seven ways to make money on youtube it's
a it's a two-part video that i did that
breaks down seven different ways that
you can monetize your youtube channel i
see that you're doing youtube views as
one of the ways and affiliate marketing
so you've got two but i have five more
that you can go through when you go to
thinkmediasale.com
and access what we have for you today so
uh that would be my review for how to
get you to full time and we're gonna
pass it over to sean
yeah
so
man what a rally got another channel got
some really powerful tips coming up
smash
the like button uh we've given away a
bunch of youtube secrets today shout out
to facebook uh watching live think media
podcast channel
if you didn't know i know some people on
facebook were saying i didn't know i
went to think media i didn't even see
that they were live we actually have two
channels
we have a podcast it's called the think
media podcast and it has a channel
dedicated to it where we do this show
the coffee with kennel show as you can
see the logo up here we do heather's
show called the youtube made simple show
and then every tuesday we do a brand new
podcast
um that is in video and also on audio so
open up your grab your smartphone you
could open up apple podcast or spotify
wherever you like to subscribe to
podcasts and uh go ahead and check out
the think media podcast where we're
gonna help you
reach your youtube goals we're on a
mission to help ten thousand
purpose-driven people create a full-time
living doing what they love while making
a difference in the world with youtube
and so um that's the point of this
channel it's the point of our social
media it's the point of our free content
like you're getting here but if you want
an accelerator you can also jump into
our paid training which is our think
media sale and um definitely let's stay
connected and
uh before we get into this last channel
review today channel reviews are closed
we've covered a ton of channels uh look
forward to when we can do this in the
future but drop
your action item not just an aha like
maybe you learn something today but what
are you gonna do because you see
again we want you to win but you can't
win if you're just constantly
learning information but you're not it's
not leading to implementation we got to
put it into practice so what are you
going to do next you're going to redo
some of your titles you're going to
level up your channel uh
art your homepage a little bit you're
going to plan out your next video
maybe
shoot a video
when it when's your next shoot day let
us know what your next action item is
for youtube growth is it to join
thinkmediasale.com
and to go into a season of learning so
you can really put together your game
plan for
2022 let us know in the comments and the
team will be connecting with you there
we've got carrot juice podcast
on here and a couple thoughts
i've learned that
this is kind of like
a
self-proclaimed common senseologist it's
a reaction uh
reaction type of channel
on some trending stuff on some kind of i
mean i saw drake on here kid cudi on
here
saying it's a podcast so uh i don't know
if you're also putting this out on
audio as well but definitely react in
your news and i think there's a lot of
opportunity there and you've got a lot
of views
um i definitely i i actually i think i
like your thumbnails they're simple but
the first thing that hit me was your
cover image and there's just so much
happening
there's a stretch face photo of you
there's the suit photo of you there's a
photo of you holding something i don't
know what you're holding there's the
diamond i don't know there's the fresh
juice served weekly which i do into it
that at least i'm probably gonna get a
video a week
um
there's the carrot juice podcast common
sense with the twist join this community
for coverage on popular culture modern
dating finances personal development and
much more
like if you try and do everything it
ends up becoming almost nothing
is what i'm feeling
it's a lot of noise there's
there's so many things and and i think
that
on the one hand our cover image isn't
going to be the thing that makes or
breaks what it is
but there's just way too much happening
like let's simplify things down
when it comes to youtube and online
marketing and online business if you
confuse you lose and if you try and do
everything it ends up almost just
becoming noise and we can't afford to
just have noise with how much
competition there is we want to
we so let me challenge you
to try to make a one sentence what i
guess it is one sentence but there's so
many commas
a one sentence pitch a one sentence
elevator pitch of what this whole thing
is
you don't have to say and it could
actually just be the channel name you
don't have to actually have a
description and what you actually want
is the content honestly spoke for itself
as soon as i saw your thumbnails i was
like this is kind of like pop culture
commentary
um
and if that's not the message you want
to send that's the message i got when i
looked at the channel
additionally as omar mentioned earlier
um 80 roll for your avatar you got this
great picture
in the suit
um but you're so there's so much black
around the photo there's it's you know
your tie you're like
you're it's kind of dark it could be
brighter it could be more zoomed in
and it also does not tell me the story
of
what the channel channel's about it to
me it seems
like it's comedy maybe it's not actually
comedy
but it certainly looks that way because
you got old stretchy face right here so
that kind of makes me feel like there's
some lightness to it
juxtaposed with super serious lawyer
mode business mode suit so
a lot of what we're talking about here
is branding
like what is your brand messaging what
is your channel messaging what what what
message is your cover image send your
your cover art what message is your
your uh picture sending and again you
come to these channel reviews for the
coaching right
when it comes to winning online here's
my opinion
clarity is more important than being
clever
uh clarity is more important than being
cute
clarity is more important than even
being creative
because if someone goes wow it's so such
a creative cover image i don't know what
it means but it's very creative
you want to cut through the noise with
clarity
and just one thing i noticed on the
about page i mean it was it's clever it
says
you have like the serving size like the
nutrition facts are that it's going to
be 15 minutes to 45 minutes servings per
container 32 like i don't know what that
means i mean i kind of get what you're
doing but it's like amount per serving
zero calories
okay
sodium why is the sodium one percent
carbohydrates so 100 protein 100 vitamin
c but no calories like i'm actually
confused i'm like this is it's carrot
carrot juice maybe that's carrot juice
you know what i'm saying and so
i i i get that's kind of branding
but this is what it's doing to at least
this viewer i'm like okay so i mean i
see it's a play on carrot juice but care
juice is
is the serious guy in the thumbnail but
it's actually kind of like
you see what i'm saying so if you
confuse you lose
you are experiencing some great views
some great impact
my friends if you want to hit the next
level of growth though and carrot juice
you want to hit the next level of growth
dial it in clarify the branding clarify
the messaging and cut through the noise
by um
applying some of those tips all right
finally
as we kind of land uh the plane here uh
i think
you know the last
thing i would say is you know success
leaves clues make part twos clearly when
you cover the right thing at the right
time
in this case uh uh an alleged split you
know a divorce or something uh then then
that was popular so you know what can
you learn about
these moments
um and how can you double down and then
apply what heather had mentioned
i definitely see you've got a model here
maybe by reacting and going live 34
uploads
makes sense 68 000 views
what do you want to happen carrot juice
you know what is it
that you are after here
i don't really know why this has no
views
that's that seems weird to me whereas
this one had 700
so
i could
yeah i mean
i think there's just some
tweaks you could do and then final
thought here is on your homepage
i don't think shorts
they may or may not even need to be
part of
a short shelf may not need to even be
on your playlist on your homepage
because it's not really optimized for
desktop
nevertheless think about this experience
i come to your homepage
you've got these common sense things and
now we're out here
and you're doing workout motivation
so i'm i'm confused more because and so
shorts are not even the best experience
workout grocery shopping
tick-tock girls
so i don't even know what the shorts are
these were two months ago then we
actually get to your uploads
that could be maybe better positioned as
in
you know what exactly is it so sometimes
we're out here trying to be creative
is it
you know
pop culture chem you know commentary
it just helps
and and they do speak for themselves
once i see those thumbnails so there i
think there's a lot in there to chew on
in terms of positioning your branding
and evolving your strategy i really
appreciate you uh submitting your
channel for channel review and carrot
juice i would encourage you of course if
you haven't heard about our sale i know
i think you've been here but
um one of the things friends watching
this that you
uh that i want to encourage you to check
out that's worth
if all you got was this it would be
worth the price of this bundle that's
eighty percent off i mean you're getting
almost two thousand dollars worth of
hard cost on this training here's your
faculty you're going to learn from
heather myself uh omar uh tony's on the
youtube strategy workshop as well so all
four of us are gonna be a part of this
but this this first section just this
alone i think one of the big things we
saw here today
was that we could level up our clarity
you're going to get our youtube clarity
blueprint
which is a multi-page pdf download that
is actually going to help you get razor
sharp
clarity
in your youtube strategy your youtube
branding who you're trying to reach
we've learned that clarity is everything
in fact it's it's just so foundational
because think about it if your
foundation isn't set right nothing else
is going to be right the walls are going
to be crooked a house can't stand
like the foundation of your youtube
channel clarity and your strategy
clarity and your branding clarity and
your messaging
and you're going to love that clarity
blueprint it's a part of the overall
bundle it's 80 off right now for cyber
week so definitely check out
and specifically if you feel like man i
need clarity in my niche or i feel like
i just need a fresh perspective and
maybe didn't get your channel reviewed
today um but you're looking for clarity
you're looking for the next steps i want
to encourage you to check out
thinkmediasale.com you're going to uh
love
that offer and let us know if you have
any questions about that well we have
been rallying friends we are here thank
you heather thank you omar thank you
tony smash like if you got value today
uh can we show some love to the think
media crew
two hours 21 minutes
and uh we are so grateful for you that
you hung out with us on a saturday on a
holiday weekend uh this has all been a
part of what we're calling think media
tech week
there's a lot of content on our other
channel think media that can help you
with cameras and tech and uh we
appreciate you so much for just being a
part of the stream today thank you
facebook for being here thank you jeremy
thank you tutorials mag thank you reward
uh remote
uh music justina bonita thank you so
much for your kind words today um
heather go ahead and shout a few people
out as we land the plane yes yes i'm
over here and i see uh miss finances
here and we've got uh daryl n d uh norah
prince who do you have over here tony
i have
got my mic here i have styled
styled by
lydia cassia
you missed the tips for fashion channels
well go back and watch it on the replay
you got this and i will also shout out
kristen
awesome thank you no thank you for being
here
and uh the last one i will go and i will
talk about is apologetics guy dr
michelle del rosario love it and thank
you for being here and uh
we're excited to be doing more of these
streams in the future
omar shout out a few people as we say
goodbye today
no no you don't love the think media
team no the think media team loves you
yeah i like
cruise ships thanks thank you for being
here we're so pumped uh thank you all so
much from jessica jessica thank you for
being on the stream
um
victor the rookie card specialist
amazing episodes so glad you would hang
out with us today and uh shout out to
our boy ian fleming
the goat of all goat thumbnail creators
look out 2022
think media thumbnail channel coaching
coming in hot coming in
hot yeah thank you spectrum art studio
adam thanks y'all my friends uh my name
is sean cannell this has been coffee
with kennel make sure you're subscribed
best place to be is on youtube
on the think media podcast channel to
check out weekly uploads that are going
to help you reach your youtube
goals i can't wait to see you in the
next episode and we will talk soon peace